Bro, that's really immature of you. Bro, that's really immature
of you. Oh, you don't think I should be doing this? No. Stop.
Oh, Connor. Connor came out and defended me. Well, let me go
humiliate him real quick. Let me go prove to him that he's a
complete for trusting me. Okay. Conor's like, I don't know. I
think you see the evidence he receives stuff. Destiny comes in.
He's like, I received a ton of from that minor. I received a
ton. It's like, brother, why? Connor just Connor was just defending
you. He was literally just defending you. What are you doing,
dude? It is with precision, Ozul. It is with precision every
time that he comes in and just cuts people's legs out. I don't
know if is that the fetish. Like he's going to get people to
defend him and then he's going to humiliate them by make them
make them making them look I Dude, thank god this guy's in media.
Actually, never mind. We don't want to cancel him. Thank god
he's in media. Could you imagine him being a cop and there's
evidence of a crime on Kiwi Farms and he's just like, "Oh, well,
you know, I was going to I was going to investigate this, but
I can't now." That apparently that information is on Kiwi Farms.
That's That's broken. I can't I can't look at that anymore.
And he actually learned that he doesn't want to be with a minor.
Okay. Well, I just told Quick Aiden clip. Quick Aiden >> Everyone
involved in this story. Everyone involved in this story needs
to die immediately.
>> Uh disavow. What the hell? >> The 17-year-old
needs to die. Destiny needs to die. Quean dead. Jtock dead. The
what? What? What you say me for? What? What the did I do? There's
no way he is that estrogenic that he is he's just drinking red
wine out of the bottle. There's no way. He's on his wine antar.
Okay, let's go. I support the Aiden wine antar. Okay. I didn't
think he'd get any closer to Britney Simon, but there it is.
There it [__] is. Let's go. W Aiden. Okay.
All right. Where are we going? Did this Did this thread take
off at all?
Got it. It's not taking off, guys. Not taking off. We have no
Hassanabi clips, by the way. Zero Hassanabi clips. Just the one
clip of me. Very interesting. Very, very neat. Very neat. All
right.
Some defense runners in the comments. Oh, that's the other thing
we could go through is we could just go through some of the cope
around this. I'm sure the cope around this is going to be delicious.
Delectable.
Delectable. Oh, they're going after me. Oh, hey, some people
actually saying it. Where evidence needs to be shown
and nothing else? Okay. All right. Nothing much. Nothing much.
Nothing much.
Okay. Where where are we going next? I think we're starting the
Conor thing. I might hop in the Discord. I'll see if people are
going to jump in. I want to get through a couple of these things
before I got in the Discord, but I will now hop in the Discord.
We'll see if people are going to comment. People want to talk
about this stuff.
I'm in I'm in the Collins channel. I'm going to share my screen.
I'm going to open up the Connor thing. We're going to get
on the Connor thing. All right, that title is That title is actually
Yes, title's pretty bad. Okay, title in that clip. Horrible.
Horrible. I will just be your payment. >> Oh, we got a
dono. >> The underscore unshackle donated $10. I am proud
of you for speaking up against abuse and for her friends. Imagine
being complicit in this narcissist's self-destruction.
I am free from the DG mind virus. I now call you J stalk, not
J tickle.
Oh well. Uh, we lost the end of your message there. Hold on.
Thank you very much for the 10 though. I appreciate it. Thank
you for the donation. Very much appreciate it. I'll get this
Connor clip fired up. Okay, this Connor stream fired up. We'll
take a look. Please don't have taken it down. Please don't have
taken it down. Thank >> I should have maybe archived this
stream. I think I I might have [__] up not archiving
this stream. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We got the Connor
stream. All right, we got it. Okay. Yeah, Jizz Tickle. That that
was the name for a while. Let me see if I can go find that that
message real quick and then we'll start this up.
That was I am free from the DG mind virus. I now call you Jay-Z
talk as the narcissist predator does to demean you. Uh I never
felt like it was that bad. It's that didn't seem that bad to
me. The stalker thing is like trying to paint me as anti-semite,
which is not true. I love people. Why else would I have this
on my soundboard if I did not love people, right? I'm always
ready to support people with this song. Okay. Every time. Every
time. Every time. every time.
dude, also as somebody who supports gay people,
never mind. There there's going to be a people doing thing there.
No, never mind. We could we do without that. We can do without
the the the joking anti-semitism. Okay, let's uh let's check
this stream out. I'm going to grab a drink. I'm going to use
the bathroom and then I'm in the Discord if anybody's hopping
in tonight and we can we can do some stuff. We can check this
out. I
This stream I've heard, goes pretty nuts. I don't know if I have
all the time stamps and I didn't watch it myself yet. So, this
will be my initial reaction as well. This is one of the time
stamps we got. Okay, I think this is right after his intro or
something. He was live. Let's see what he has to say. Let's check
it out. Be back into the routine.
Hi, Dis Houseion. Thank you for your donations yesterday. Hello,
Dan S. And um I was just gonna say we we got some uh
I'm I'm not gonna lie. >> I've been trying to cover other
things besides just to mix it up and make sure that we don't
become a Destiny research.
However, I don't know why. Truth be told, there's a reason why
he's the most popular streamer in liberal news media. There's
a reason why he's constantly the center of attention and drama,
and it's because he gets into fights with other people all the
time. Uh which is what we'll be talking about today. Grill Shalah.
Indeed. Indeed. Um, how old was Rose? No idea. 17, 18.
Now, I don't care. Uh, let let me tell you why I don't care.
Uh,
we already knew that. We've known that for a year. Um, that like
Rose was like living with her parents and all that kind of. So,
well, maybe not a year. Maybe November. November. So, we we've
known that she was living with her parents and it was stupid
and all that. Um, so I don't know. Se 17 years old, 364 days
and and 11 hours.
No idea. No idea. And you know what? I hope that the entire drama
of random people on the internet, bro. There is no [__]
way with that start. Holy [__] I couldn't believe
my ears as I'm listening to this. What? Sorry. I was like I was
like so annoyed. I'm like trying to use the bathroom and I'm
sitting there and I'm like I'm like twitching hearing him say
this. That's crazy.
That's all that was all insane. Guys, why don't I care about
Destiny Minor and receiving CSAM? Um, well, that's because I
knew about it a year ago to start with. To start with, I knew
about it a year ago. Is that a good answer? Is that Is that a
good answer? Why am I okay with Destiny sending or sorry, receiving
CSAM and sending to a minor? Um, well, I knew about it a year
ago. It was obvious a year ago. That's not an answer. And then
he does the 17 years, 364 days, 11 hours. No, she was under 17
1/2 apparently, right? Believe he's under 17 and 1/2. She's closer
to 17 than 18, brother. I might I'm I'm going to back it up like
30 seconds or something. I'm going to listen to this whole thing
again. My god. Oh, and I got to get that that kickbot donation
that went through as well and replay that cuz I walked away for
it. food. Is there a more terrible wingman than Connor? Gets
baited to confirm Lauren Southern and now this. It's rough. It's
rough. Let's listen. Don't know. Don't know. Hello.
>> Thank you. >> My favorite website is maps.google.com,
but for some reason it only shows me local pizza shops. I don't
know why. >> There's just so many there's
That's funny. Also, maps.google.com. And it just shows me like
geographical maps. I thought it was a site for me. I thought
it was my site. I I've been trying to cover other things besides
Destiny uh just to mix it up and make sure that we don't become
a Destiny Rewatch channel. Uh however, uh truth be told, there's
a reason why he's the most popular streamer in liberal news media.
There's a reason why he's constantly the center of attention
and drama. It's because he gets into >> Connor. Doesn't
it make you feel a little weird that this guy sees somebody very
young, he peruses a non-ageverified website for and messages
these people and then tries to get from them, share with them?
Does that not concern you as a former cop that this guy is clearly
trying to blur the lines on age of consent on on the age at which
you can send material on the internet? Does that not concern
you even a little bit, Connor? That he described how disgusting
not safe for Work Twitter was 3 months before he went on not
safe for not safe for work Twitter and solicited a minor. And
then what? 7 days after 6 or 7 days after soliciting that minor,
he goes on to send a pixie video to her. And then the day after
that, she's like, "Hey, I just got my braces off today. That's
awesome." My god. My god. fights with other people all the time.
Uh, which is what we'll be talking about today. Grill Shalah.
Indeed. Indeed. Um, how old was Rose? No idea. 17, 18.
Now, >> bro, I can't believe I can't believe the confidence
which with he with which he says that
and just like kind of he just kind of owns that, right? That's
tough. I don't think I could do that. How old is Rose? I don't
know. 17 probably. >> I don't care. Uh, let let me tell
you why I don't care. Uh,
we already knew that. We've known that for a year. Um, that like
Rose was like living with her parents and all that kind of. So,
well, maybe not a year. Maybe November. November. So, it's, by
the way, they keep trying to put it in the past further. I've
noticed this for some reason. The sweepers are always like, "Dude,
that came out a year ago. That's how it's six months since the
Pixie video today. Today's six months since the Pixie video."
Oh, sorry. Seven months since the Pixie video. Seven months.
Bad math. seven months. All right. Like a lot of people have
not been knowing this for that long and even then I'm not sure
why that would matter >> so we we've known that she was
living with her parents and it was stupid and all that. Um so
I don't know
se 17 years old 364 days and and 11 hours.
>> So that's immediately minimizing as much as possible
right immediately minimizing as much as possible. Totally.
Why would you? I don't know why you That would be your Dude,
this guy was minor. Yeah, but like wasn't she close to 18? Wasn't
she like pretty close? Wasn't she Come on, man. Come on, man.
>> No idea. No idea. And you know what? I hope that the
entire drama of random people on the internet.
>> It's uh 9 9 months and like 6 days since the original
leaks happened with the nudes. I think 9 months 6 days. So, but
then 2 months after that, 7 months, 6 days would be
pixie lawsuit, I think,
>> no 7 months >> getting homemade to various people
of having it leaked, of getting sued over it. Um, I hope that
has been and will continue to remain a wake-up call for Steven
to not be so hedonistic
and nihilistic. And that's all. >> And what evidence do
we have of this wakeup call, Connor?
What evidence is there of this wakeup call? Has he stopped being
a totally like impulsive yet at any point here? Has he decided
to stop? Has he tried to take a night off from being just the
most impulsive piece of that we can all imagine?
Or has he just continued it
night after night after night going after whoever who whoever's
he leaked, whoever he's non-consensually recorded, he just goes
after all these people, right? Where is the evidence of contrition
or any change?
Where is it? That's all we can pray for is that he becomes a
better person over >> the death threat to Hassan. Yeah.
The the actual wishing for death, the the trying to enact violence.
Okay. Actual stochcastic terrorism on Hassan. I guess we're just
not really going to comment on that. We're not really listen.
He's guys, I think he's learned not to be so hedonistic. When
he when he said Han should be I think that was the sign that
hedonism has ended for him. Okay, >> we're time. So anyways,
beef supreme says bueno migos
migo. Uh, I'm not trying to say goodbye. I'm just trying to say
random Spanish phrases. Steven Drum is always fun. True. Uh,
Tim Zealot says, "Can't really get behind prayer one as it conflicts
with commandment one, but I can appreciate the sentiment." Well,
fair enough. Beef Supreme says, "I share nudes on the internet.
It's really fun." Uh, stop. Stop immediately. Uh, stop posting
your andor t andor vagina and or butthole on the internet unless
you want other people to see it. And uh yeah, please stop, you
know, stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop posting your your
private areas on the internet
says he'll get there one day probably I mean maybe yeah same
same same I'm I'm with you like I'm Steven's friend I consider
myself Steven's friend I'm going to continue to hang out with
him uh but there's an opport
like like if those if those Twitter logs are real Connor has
to stop right like that's incredibly obvious that he is concerned
that person's a minor and then he engaged in a sex relationship
with them. That has to be the line for the Christian conservative
former cop. No. Is that not the line? If those are real, how
in the world could that not be the line? There's a total possibility
that just within the next 5 years, uh, we're hanging out at the
studio and then he opens up the freezer and there's just like
severed human heads and he's like he's like, "Listen, Connor,
like we've been friends for a while. Realistically, you knew
this was a possibility." And I'll be like, "Yeah, I didn't think
it was a probability, but it was >> Uhhuh." Okay. So, no,
there is no point,
really? Yeah. Even if he was a serial killer, I'd probably still
hang out with him. Okay. Uh,
so you're just a horrible person. You're just like a totally
principalist piece of [__] right? Like, this is just
him going, "Yeah, I I really shouldn't have a platform. I shouldn't
be on the internet. I'm a total piece of I have no principles.
I will do whatever I can for money. Uh, you should not you should
not support me. You should not pay attention to me. I am not
worth listening to. That's exactly what Connor is laying out
for for us right now. That's wild. >> It was a possibility.
Radio Shanks is not being a lunatic with other streamers and
only normies is a start. Sure. Sure. But uh le let's you know
le let's thank the the content gods that that Steven has been
such a >> oh you know I don't really I don't really engage
in like being that concerned about random chatters but it is
his mod saying hopefully those heads are stalker and queen
okay so yeah Connor's mod wishing for us to be that's >> trailblazer
reference to content to the point that now we can watch him >> by
the way I can identify that that's a joke and not be a total
fs slur about it. Okay, I can I can identify that that's a joke.
I'm not that concerned. >> Argue with Hassan [__]
whether or not he can stochcastically call for violence against
YouTube's biggest
uh biggest uh podcasting family. You know, at least we have the
content. Christian Blair says, "Hopefully those heads are JTO
and Creamman." Jesus Christ.
I disavow. That's a stochcastic call for violence against Quean
and Jtock. And as far as I know, they're they're only guilty
of harboring a toxic community of anti-fan schizophrenics. >> Nope.
Literally just a ton of people who are Well, for me, I would
I think for Queen the anti-fan label is inappropriate. Okay.
He just harbors a community of schizophrenics. And for me, I
harbor a community of anti-fans who were the biggest Destiny
fans that existed until he showed his app. Okay. Until he showed
who he was. Okay, that's different for both of us for different
reasons. Anti-fense schizos are worse than really mad. Yeah,
apparently. Who may or may not be doxing Steven? So, you know,
uh, is that a crime? It's a succulent Chinese me. What's the
charge?
>> What's the charge? Harboring a toxic community of anti-fans.
A succulent community of anti-fans.
By the way, a lot of the people in my community who really hate
Destiny have reasons to like explicitly really hate Destiny,
right?
Like I've got got Jacob and Zoe there. I feel like Jacob doesn't
like Destiny. He's got every reason not to like Destiny. Destiny's
trying to dox him, trying to put his information out there, trying
to intimidate him, talking [__] about his loved ones,
a whole bunch of [__] about Jacob, right? Like, I'm
sorry. Destiny directly addresses and makes these people hate
him. So, you could say they're anti-fans, but in, you know, in
the real world, we just call that like people you've made enemies
of, people you hate, like actual people you dislike. Like, it's
not like there's no social interaction. It's not like it's one
unidirectional, right? Jacob's talked to Destiny directly. Lots
of us have talked to Destiny directly. It's not like parasocial
in any way. It's just social and us disliking you. Critics. Sure.
Critics. Yeah. Now, what what Nerd Knight says here, sorry, we're
anti and offenders. I I would say you probably want to say we're
anti and anti offenders. Okay. I don't that reads a little ambiguously,
a little concerning, but what's the crime? Fast and bulbous says
$5. Thank you. How are you sleepy at the beginning of streams?
I thought we all agreed after we turned 30 that we all woke up
at 5:00 a.m. every day. Absolutely. Also, >> absolutely
not. Absolutely. >> Also, [__] it. Okay, [__]
it.
>> We're not hitting critical mass on Twitch today. That's
okay. We're going to end the Twitch stream. We're going to head
over to kick, guys. kick.com/jstlk.
Head over to kick.com/jlk.
Going to continue the stream there. Thank you very much for showing
up tonight on Twitch. All right, we're going to keep going with
the content, but I will see you guys over on kick. kick.com/jstlk.
All right, let me shut off multireaming.
No more sacrificing that revenue. All that sweet revenue. Head
over to kick. Let's go. >> Absolutely not. I am a night
owl. My my most productive hours are between 1000 p.m. and 3.
>> Is he not Oh, that's a good question. Connor, if your
BFF is Dexter and serial killers, do you condemn? Oh, this is
like a this is the implication that Destiny is righteous in his
doxing, which is insane.
>> Now, I went to bed at 1:00 a.m. last night cuz I knew
I had a busy day today, but still, no. Absolutely not. Night
Owls.
Night Owls.
Christian Blair says, "Throw in Kelly Jean so I never have to
hear her gaslighting again." Jeez.
Everyone about
>> Hold on. I should have I should have left my Twitch
stream running. Hassan's probably about to end soon. Okay, you
know what? Cather meanwhile chat is fantasizing about the serial
kill
spree of Stephan Steven Benell
>> against his uh
against his auntie fans. Sen Patty says being mean online is
illegal. I mean that's what I thought. Brandon Zero says I would
leave my comment here but I need to run back to DG. We're having
too much fun there Connor. I am watching you on TV. Be a good
influence to the kids in the house. Oh no. Jas Salian says, "Jtock
is guilty of trying to steal the moon with his gravitic." See,
see, now fat people are catching strays, dude. I'm 10 to 20 pounds
overweight. There's, you know, other fat people that are probably
in chat. Jesus Christ. >> Do you want to comment on this?
No, it's >> Why Why do fat people have to catch strays
just because, you know, Jtock has a little bit more to love.
And let's admit, he looks like a little bit of a teddy bear.
He looks like he gives great hugs.
Okay.
So, yeah, that's when you have kids, not necessarily at 30. >> Actually,
fun fact, that is true. That is true. >> Sure. Beef Supreme
says, "Hell no, I need to wait." Uh 511 180. Yeah, it is what
it is. It is what it is. I like how uh the first guy they do
was like massive. The second guy they doxed that they said was
me as well. Um not massive. And they're just going back and pretending
the second guy doesn't exist now. And I was really blank banking
on that second guy not being fat. Okay. What the [__]
I'm getting up at 5:00 a.m. I'm usually up by 8 to get kids to
school. Gotcha. Well, if you have kids, definitely stop posting
your dick to the internet. Jesus Christ. Dion says, "I'm a fat."
See? See? Now, now fat people are catching strays just because
you want to make fun of Jto. That's very rude. Fat people give
great hugs. >> Very rude. >> We know this scientifically.
Fat people give great hugs.
So, I don't even know what JTO looks like. He looks like a nice
guy. He He looks like uh He looks like a a chunky realworld South
Park character that gives great hugs. That's what he looks like.
>> Apparently, this guy is just like, "Yeah, just straight
up like going to talk about doces and stuff,
>> Bulbous. Ew. Imagine having kids, putrid. See, that's
the kind of antiatalist I need to grab you by your shoulders
and shake out of you. Although you are the first super chatter
of the day, so I guess I have to give you some level some level
of grace. Belle says, "Fat people unite." Indeed, indeed. Mr.
Universe says, "I'm a skinny. I give great hugs." Oh, that's
good. That's good. Beef Supreme says, "I'm very comfortable with
my body. Nothing to be shy and ashamed of." Good, good, good,
good, good. Love them big girls though. That's excellent. That's
excellent. I was going to share, so I've been um you guys know
that I try to lift routinely. I actually haven't lifted since
last week since the DC trip, so I need to need to get back in
the grind. Uh but um no PES, just just lifting, just doing the
Dad Bod routine. Uh what I added into my routine though is my
kids go to bed around 8:00. Now, realistically, that means between
8 and 9, so I don't know when they really go, but we try to get
them down around 8. And so, what I've been doing is right after
the kids go to bed, right before I do my night's work, I have
the two dogs and I'm trying to walk them almost daily um at night
time during that perfect window at >> I think I think food
shops got the Destiny raid equid.
So, that's the big >> little nappy, but you're not quite
ready to go to bed. I've been walking the dogs and it's just
a 20 minute walk. It's just around the block. It's block walk
block. Um you know, probably quarter mile, half a mile. It's
really not that long, but it gets the heart pumping. It makes
those little micro muscles and your hips and your legs work.
Uh it does all that kind of stuff. And so strong recommend that
if you're kind of flagging in the evening, feel substantially
better. So lift weights three to four times a week. How like
do the dad body workout routine, but also add in three to five
walks per week uh right before you go to bed and you'll >> Hold
on, hold on, hold on. This is misinformation.
Hey, Jay Stalking Kelly made pretty atrocious comments about
Steven's looks calling him fat for a year straight. It's been,
by the way, 7 months,
and I only did those comments for like a month of that. And and
not only that, Kelly did way worse. Okay. Objectively, she went
hard. All right. I had like two streams. Oh, yeah. But exactly.
This is the thing again. It's a whole year. It's been a year
they've been doing it straight.
You don't even watch the stream. Shut the up. >> Probably
start seeing results. [__] True. I thought someone
was posting the Oreo. Dang.
I'm just leaving people for mids. I'm usually around 3:30 in
the
>> Yeah. That's a tough schedule.
There's nothing like a really good hug from the fluffy people.
Yeah. >> Is this important?
>> Like 900 viewers right now. Okay. Bye. J says, "Went
to university." Oh, come on. Um, that's like a micro doc, but
I guess he went to Saskatchewan, I guess, and that place sucks.
I guess that's what you're saying. Okay, I guess Saskatchwan
>> bro. If this was real, this would be so weird,
bro. You pulling up you pulling up like hyperspecific docs information
on somebody on your stream. That's
>> Just sad. True, >> brother. I like Oreo, too,
just by myself. Sure. Sure. I love your Oreo. He's a pack. I
know. For sure. Say, I wish I was being fat and not skinny fat.
I'm slim with your belly. Well, then you need to add in walks
and you eat. You need to add the dadbot fitness routine into
your life. Uh to be clear, it's actually very very >> Sorry,
I'm just speeding through this cuz it's only sporadically that
we get any comments on this stuff. Uh what do I want to do? We're
going to watch this. I've got a lot of other time stamps, but
he apparently goes sporadically in and out of this stuff for
the three.
I'm not using any fancy equipment. I literally have 20 pound
dumbbells next to me right now, and that's all I use. So, uh
three bicep exercises, three back exercises, that's one day.
Next, uh and you're doing 10 10 reps of each exercise three times.
So, three sets of 10 for three exercises. It actually works only
like 20 to 30 minutes. Good lord. >> Um, so back and biceps
one day, chest and triceps another day, shoulders and forms another
day, and then legs another day. In the way, but I do legs.
>> They said my was ugly. Look at all these chat messages
saying my is ugly. Look at them. Look at them. Look at them.
Look at them. >> Let me find it.
>> This is called I think it's like a monkey foot or a
monkey claw. And basically what it is, it's a it's a >> Oh,
I've got these. These are I don't have one of these. I've got
a friend who's got one. You put like a weight on the end of it
and you could do like leg raises with it. And there's a bunch
of stuff you could do. You could like basically this is like
key to training. Um I'll [__] there's like some interior
like hip muscle that you can train with this that is like you
can't do it any other way. You need this monkey foot thing. Yeah.
You train your hip flexors with them. And there's like no other
way to just isolate your hip flexors like quite as well without
having like really good um like uh like body weight exercise
mobility and stuff. Like if you if you do like a lot of body
weight exercises, you do like CrossFit or something, you usually
have pretty strong hip flexors. But if you sit in a chair a lot
of the time, these are actually like golden. >> Ski boot
that has a lock at the bottom and then this locks over it and
so you put your weights in the bottom of it and then you do hamstring
curls, leg extensions, and that's really it. Um I also do calf
raises, but you don't need the boot for that. And that's why
I do legs. I do three three sets of three sets of 10 of leg extension
add. I don't like the standard that if somebody engages in schizophrenic
negative behavior that we engage in schizophrenic negative behavior
back that still makes you a schizophrenic person. So yeah, just
purposes good dude. Heart health for the win. Yeah. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Oh, well says, "I do farm work and ride my bike by
208 miles." You're fine. That's almost You don't need to do anything.
You're fine. >> Petty says, "My secret to weight loss is
taking ADHD meds and not eating outside of toast in the morning."
Jesus Christ. Okay, well, that's not going to be that's good
in the short term, not the long term. Beef Supreme says, "My
wife ran over straight kidney in our driveway this morning. I
was consoling her and she was asking what she should do. I told
her she needed to sacrifice some bird eggs to the gods balance
restored." Jesus Christ.
Okay, weed. Lauo got really, really, really mad that I commented
positively on the monkey claw. I actually have a friend who does
like some pretty specific stuff and he's got one of those that
he said it was awesome. Whatever the that thing is >> that
is sad hitting a stray kitten but you know what go to a stray
kitten you'll be fine
just by eating right in plain I are impressive but it's some
in fact bodies are unhealthy too about even before nowhere by
the carnivore diet but that's off people's people >> okay
I don't know
>> ri if you're here and you're listening tell me if I
keep going on this girl says no vegetable at all is pretty crazy
it is it is you have to eat vegetables and vegetables are not
known for being inflammatory there might be some like random
thing shoes no never get in your diet to fight inflammation And
I do, but cashews on
if I eat cashew. >> I'm skipping through. >> I have
I have Philip DeFranco as my opener for the >> Okay, you
know what? I'm going to skip to the next time stamp. If this
is just If this is just yapping, I'm going to wait for Ry to
send me a message on this. We keep going. Okay. Okay, we keep
going. Look at the other timestamps.
Let's check it out. That is a super big problem. CPA says, "I
can understand you wanting to support your friend, I guess, but
working with someone to 17-year-old seems crazy politically,
but you do you, I guess." Well, thanks for that. Um,
>> Do you Does anybody have EV? >> Hold on. Did you
just see how many things he just skipped through here? >> Snarkers
love to stir the pot. Hold on. Is there something before >> Pangerine
just tipped $25?
>> Horton's on today, big guy. Any news today? There are
there is some news today. Richie, thank you very much for the
25. Okay. Yeah. Turns out she really there was a lot of reason
to ask how old is Rose. Turns out that was an important question
for a while here. Okay. >> Super bad. I I'll say even a
generation ago.
I would say it was probably like 80% of men had some kind of
relationship.
Like you held hand relationships between 15 and 20. I I feel
like there was a comment before this that something popped up
and am I crazy? Oh yeah, there's a comment back here. Heard you
swept for >> a unique woman problem or man problem when
we're talking about like the loneliness epidemic. >> It's
a male skewed issue. Um right like men in the pure research men
between the ages of like 18 to 25 60.
>> Oh, he skipped it. That's why. Hold on. He skipped that
one. And it was Caz
heard you sweat for Destiny 17-year-old. kind of sad you've fallen
so low 60%
of them I think hadn't even dated before whereas I think it was
only like 30% of young women >> doesn't it doesn't it >> sort
of I mean >> these women are dating
>> who's your favorite streamer like just out of curiosity
is it >> do you >> do you watch JTock do you watch
Queman who do you watch who do you watch that tells you these
things >> watch Riyle Kittenhouse VODs do you watchman
do you watch Ched Logic and by the way like I like Chudlogic
I I watch Queman's content So, CPAZ, uh, this is my first time
seeing you. Who's your favorite streamer? Just out of >> Uh,
I like Destiny, Mr. Girl, and food shops. But number four, Connor,
it's all you, baby. It's all you, baby. >> The men are
not. That means the women are dating all the same guys. >> Well,
no, they're not. Like, most of these women are in monogous relationships,
right? The the issue is actually the 20-year-olds are dating
like men that are typically like four to 5 years older than them.
That's actually more so what we're seeing. So let's just that's
a I actually say uh I have a 5y year age gap between my wife
and I I think being a 30 engaging with the
>> I used to watch Destiny Queen Chud you >> the
idea is I think you'll find you watch a lot of Twitch pull in
general. Okay, that's cool. Um I I think that it'll be rare for
you to find me ever saying that uh Steven being a 30-year-old
man homemade to a very young woman. I I doubt you'll find any
clips of me saying that's good or neutral. I would say it's bad.
Uh, but I'm also just not going to, I don't know, throw them
under the bus for pironic cannibalistic Twitch pole people. So,
have fun though. >> Break it down for my misunderstanding
then cuz it sounds like I might be misunderstanding most. >> So,
I disavow him. Nope. Disavow. Uh, disavow involves like an extra
level of uh like uh disassociation, right? Disavow definition.
We're getting one guy again, but truth be told, could be fun.
Deny any responsibility or support for um I don't have any responsibility
for Steven being a degenerate. As a matter of fact, I've criticized
him and strongly encouraged him against the
>> Uh, I would say if you're
I don't know if you could say that you've you've got some responsibility
for promoting him, right? And you do promote him hardcore. If
he is actually like victimizing people, if you had reason to
believe he was engaging in a pattern of behavior that that led
you to believe he was attracted to very young people who probably
couldn't have a sex relationship with him, would it not be incumbent
on you to not promote that person? What do you mean?
How do you react to the Vosh lolly stuff? He said Bosch was a
degenerate, but he kind of swept for him because he's a progressive
victory. The real question is how did how did Connor react to
Chud Logic having food shops on his stream?
How did Connor react to that? And the answer is he said, "You
should never do that. It's wrong to do that." So, when it was
a small person, okay, he was ready. He was right there to say,
"You need to disavow this person." But as they get bigger, okay,
as they get more clout, Connor<unk>'s age of consent goes
down. Connor's age of consent for Destiny is like three. Okay.
He needs to know if Destiny has a [__] 2-year-old.
Don't tell Connor. He doesn't give a [__] Okay.
If Destiny were to double the size of his platform, I'm not sure
there's a being on Earth that you could actually get Connor to
to denounce Destiny for trying to I don't think there is. I don't
think there's anything. Okay.
Could be a rodent. I don't think Connor would have heat for it.
Um, I support Steven in so far as uh I consider him a friend
and I support him trying to take alt media and have real world
impact. That's what I support Steven in. Um, as far as supporting
specifically his generacy, not really. And I hope he grows up.
So, no, I don't disavow him. Uh, I'm not going to disassociate
from him. Uh, however, I will be critical of the behavior and
I hope he grows up and stops doing it. Stop people. Stop making
homework. Stop being generous. Find your wife. Get married. Have
kids. What was the number most of men have found relationships?
Uh 30% of women have dated between the ages of 18 and 25 where
61% of men have not dated. >> Right. Okay. So So that's
the same between the ages of 18 and 25 where 61% of men have
not dated. >> Oh, I missed it then. My mistake. So you
just So that's the same number, isn't >> Sorry, I I'm not
understand. >> That means 30% of men have dated and 30%
of women have dated. >> No, 61% of men between the ages
of 18 to >> Bro, the the boys will be boys rhetoric kind
of makes sense when they're like 16, 17, 18, 19. Once they start
hitting like 25 or for example 37,
then is it not weird to say like, "Oh, they'll just grow up."
Hopefully they'll grow up. Hopefully they'll grow up someday.
Really, man? I really hope this guy's going to grow up. Bro,
that's really immature of you. Bro, that's really immature of
you. Oh, you don't think I should be doing this? No. Stop 17-year-olds.
They're immature. Okay, it's really immature of you to try to
that 17-year-old in terms of your tastes are for immature women.
>> 25 have not had a relationship
as well. That's a [__] problem. If that's true, if
60% of men between the ages of 18 and 24 have not had a relationship,
that's a problem.
>> 61% of men between the ages of 18 to 25 have not had
a relationship.
>> That is super bad. I I'll say even a generation ago,
I would say it was probably like 80% of men had some kind of
relationship. 61% of men between the ages of 18 to 25 have not
had a
>> That is super bad. I I'll say even a generation ago.
I would say it was probably like 80% of men had some kind of
relationship like you held hands. >> I I'm so sorry for
subjecting you guys to the red pill for 2 seconds. >> You're
saying you're saying both 30% of >> that is a super big
problem, I guess. But working with someone 17-year-old seems
crazy politically, but you do you, I guess. Well, thanks for
that. Um, do
>> seems crazy politically? >> I saw me there. Hold
on. >> Who hasn't been talked into recording degeneracy
by a 22-year-old
>> at fashion 40? It's from KF and Jtock. Not true. Not
true that it's from me. Okay, that's not true. >> Do you
Does anybody have evidence that she was 17?
>> Um, the >> You already said Why would it matter
if there was evidence, Connor? You already said she was 17 and
everybody knew that. Rose girl. I I don't Is there something
new? Cuz you're you're not the first person. There's like half
a dozen people who are like, "Destiny's bad. Destiny's bad. Disavow
him now." So, I'm curious. >> I'm have dated. >> So,
that means 30% of men have had a >> Uh-oh. Connor just
up. Conor just asked for proof. >> Sorry. Did I mess up?
>> Yes. On KF? Well, I mean, that's our first problem.
Uh, but realistically, what's why
why would that why would why if somebody posted the evidence
of that on KF? I dude, thank god this guy's in media. Actually,
never mind. We don't want to cancel him. Thank god he's in media.
Could you imagine him being a cop and there's evidence of a crime
on Kiwi Farms? And he's just like, "Oh, well, you know, I was
going to I was going to investigate this, but I can't now." That
apparently that information is on Kiwi Farms. That's that's broken.
I can't I can't look at that anymore. Wow. >> What's the
evidence on KF?
>> Did I miss? >> You're saying both. >> Uh,
but realistically, what's the evidence on KF?
>> Oh, but still, what's the evidence? >> Did I miss
>> You're saying both 30% of women have have not dated?
>> They have not dated. >> Sorry. Yeah. Sorry. So,
that so if it's two to one men not dating but women are dating,
then the women would have to be >> Well, between that age
Well, no, no, no, no. That's the age bracket. 18 to 25 is one
of the key things. >> Okay. But the point >> women
are dating older men. >> Oh, I see. I see. I see. >> What
is this?
What is this? What is this? Hold on a second. >> I've been
trying to Hold on. Counterpoints. Famous ex- cop of three years
who patrolled the high school. Doesn't care how old Rose was.
Good thing he's not a cop anymore. Just another influencer for
hire minimizing all of Destiny's illegal and violative actions.
Real cops probably really care about this kind of stuff.
>> They cover other things besides Destiny. Uh just to
mix it up and make sure that we don't a Destiny Rewatch channel.
>> Uh, however, uh, truth be told, there's a reason why
he's the most popular streamer in liberal news media. There's
a reason why he's constantly the center of attention and drama,
and it's because he gets into fights with other people all the
time. Uh, which is what we'll be talking about today. Grill Shalah.
Indeed. Indeed. >> Um, how old was Rose? No idea. 17, 18.
Now, I don't care. Uh, let let me tell. See, that's what he said
earlier. I listen, she was 17 or 18. >> Tell you why I
don't care. Uh, >> he doesn't care. >> We already
knew that. We've known that for a year. Um, that like Rose was
like living with her parents and all that kind of
Well, maybe not a year. Maybe November. November. So, we we've
known that she was living with her parents and it was [__]
stupid and all that. Um, so I don't know. Se 17 years old, 364
days and and 11 hours. That is particularly like the grossest
part of this that he did that. Like you could just say you don't
care, but don't like not look into this and go, "Oh, it's the
don't do the maximum minimalization, right?" That's insane to
me that you would just not inform yourself and then do that kind
of minimizing. Like don't say, "Oh, I can't look at I don't can't
look at Kiwi Farms if that's what the evidence is." And then
say and then do the minimization. Right. Sorry. This is why if
you wondered why I flipped on counterpoints kind of out of nowhere,
it was listening to the first like 5 minutes of his stream from
today was just like goofy as um I guess this was kind of obvious
before, but I'm I'm finding it less entertaining.
I figured at some point he would have like a a time where he
stops and he just hasn't stopped ever. Just keeps like letting
go of his principles one by one over time. >> No idea.
No idea. And you know what? I hope that the entire drama of random
people on the internet, of sending homemade to various people,
of having it leaked, of getting sued over it. Um, I hope that
has been and will continue to remain a wake-up call for Steven
to not be so hedonistic
and nihilistic. >> Wow,
guys. I I just really hope this is a wakeup call. I hope you
like grow up, you know? I hope you really just grow up and be
like a better, more mature person. This 37year-old, listen, boys
will be boys, okay? Boys will be boys. This 37year-old's going
to grow up and it's going to be great. All right? It's going
to be
It's going to be great. He's going to learn from this. He's going
to be better. It's going to be better. Wow. Thank you, Connor.
>> That's what's making up the gap. >> I think everyone
agrees with that, >> Well, uh, yeah. I mean, the reality
is, you know, average women don't want average men. they date
up and now with you know the way we have society
>> oh actually this is a good point okay remains a wakeup
call so like a dude Connor's like I know it probably won't actually
stay in his head and he probably will revert to this kind of
behavior but I hope that it like this is the last time we have
to go through this I hope this is the last time I have to deal
with people saying I sweep for a I'm not certain and I I'm acknowledging
that I'm not certain but I hope it's the last time fingers crossed
guys >> is not only reinforced but it's encouraged u you
know women are told to not settle They're told to get the best
man that they can get. So, a lot of girls think that they qualify
for something a lot of times, which they actually don't. Um,
and sometimes I have to be the reality and let them know like,
look, you're average. You got to be, you know, a little bit more
realistic about where you stand. >> This isn't really average
women don't want average men. >> This isn't really hypergamy,
though, right? Like, what are men typically selecting for in
relationship? Youthfulness, beauty, right? Some level of like
making him feel good. What are women selecting for? >> Are
you arguing against the red pill when Destiny is your business
partner? >> I don't know. >> I don't know anymore.
So in this way, women are dating the pool of men that give them
the stability factor cuz it usually men a couple years to get
education. The pool of men. >> Hold on. What was that?
Cut forms is so trustworthy. Well, the place that won't take
down Desty's vids along with Pixie >> that give them the
stability.
>> Uh that has nothing to do with the trustworthiness of
the information. You're you're comparing along two different
axes. Yeah, it's immoral that they won't remove those videos,
but it's not the same as being uh inaccurate, right? you'd be
immoral and accurate >> factors cuz it usually takes men
a couple of years to get education and a career and like something
built underneath them and men are selecting for the things that
they want. >> Sorry, we're we're getting a little bit woneyed,
but you know, it's hot. >> Always pay attention to the
source of the information. That's like me believing you hurt
your dog/kids because I read it from a thread that dedicates
on hating you.
Um, yeah, you shouldn't actually read somebody's like skits or
rambling and believe it. But if it's a clip of them saying something,
right, like the clip of Destiny going through that not safe for
work Twitter stuff, that MNSFW thing and going like, "Oh, there's
a lot of minors posting on Twitter, right? That's a clip that
is that can just be standalone and you can think whatever you
want from it. I'm never going to hate Destiny archival information
coming from a site that hates him. That doesn't make any sense.
>> Drama, so whatever." Um, Brandon Zero says, "Pay attention
to the source of the information. That's like me believing you
hurt your dog's kids because I read it from a thread that uh
>> Welp. After my incel war room failed to find her, I
was convinced the cleanup job was perfect and I could finally
get a dunk on Blav. But I am >> Thank you very much for
the five, Destiny. Appreciate it. Appreciate it. >> Dedicated
on hating on you for sure. Um but I think that the
the narrative was
>> Uh this is true. Tequila Sun. Yes, he did think it was
reliable enough for his Keell's manifesto. He did think there
was nothing wrong with archival information. He did believe in
the site's right to exist. He didn't disavow the site. He posted
on the site. He posted in his own thread. >> Knew that
she was young. Um how young, no idea. >> Uh but realistically,
like yeah, it's bad behavior, right? I don't think Steven's going
to jail, right?
Um so if it's bad behavior, why? Hold on. If she was provably
17 and he he has already signed an affidavit saying he sent to
her. Why would you say now that he is? He's definitely not going
to jail. Right. He's definitely he's definitely not going to
jail. Right. Right. He's definitely not going to He's definitely
not going to jail. Huh? What? He also floated the idea of funding
KF's legal defense. He did. Yeah. I try to I try to say it like
he floated the idea. Yes. A lot of people will say he he tried
to or he did fund. He did not. I don't think he ever did because
he's >> And it's from 2022.
Then we can throw that in the same quote unquote disavowel pile
as the rest of the drama. We can just say, "Yeah, it's bad."
>> Wait, what? Hold on. >> Behavior, right? I don't
think Steven's going to jail, right? Um, so I'm not paying attention.
And it's from 2022.
Then we can throw that in the same quote unquote disavowel pile
as the rest of the drama. We can >> Thank god this guy's
not a cop anymore. Okay. Uh, that guy, that guy three years ago,
that guy, that guy was a kid three years ago. Okay, that guy
was [__] Why would we care about that?
It's bad. What do you want me to do? Get off my ass. No. No thank
you. You need a pile of No, Cosmo. No. If you need a pile of
disavowels, maybe that's the problem. Hey, Connor, if you're
like, well, I can throw it in the same disavow pile as all the
other time this guy's had weird degenerate drama. Okay,
maybe if you're saying that, you've already picked a loser candidate.
What do you think? >> Just say, "Yeah, it's bad." So, yeah,
it's bad. Don't if you're if you're over the age of 18, don't
people under the age of 18. Boom. Easy. He's actually
It's bad. What do you want me to say? Sending. Sorry. Receiving
CSAM.
Soliciting CSAM. That's wild. That's pretty wild. It's pretty
crazy.
>> Don't do it. Stop gooning. Get married. Have kids. >> Which
way, white man? Which way, young man? Which way? Young white
man. >> Sure. No, I mean this is my first time seeing CPASS
2. I'm not saying I'm not skeptical. I'm just saying we can be
dis Yes or no. Yes or no? Do you disavow?
>> I just went to Cav and they're calling for his death
and celebrating he was allegedly as a child.
That's up.
That's
>> No. Anyways, uh dealing with the content though because
I do think this is interesting. So, if we have this problem
of 18 to 24 year old women where
uh you know uh >> I'm gonna I'm gonna guess that's where
we finish with that time stamp. Let's keep looking. Let's keep
taking a look. Let's keep taking a look. Let's keep looking.
Let's keep looking. We've got Where is my Hold on. I lost these
timestamps. I put them in my document. One second. We'll go to
the next time stamp. We'll keep looking at Connor here. Next
one's right here. Keep >> Crisis. And we've got no young
people. >> Ryan Cougler says, "Has Connor commented on
the story of the day, chat? Thanks in advance." Yeah. Uh, Steven's
a But your guys evidence of him being a is that he allegedly
sent videos to a 17-year-old girl who definitely received as
well. Def 100% received has talked about receiving many videos
from her. >> Send 17-year-old videos back. >> In
fact, I believe also confessed to this in his chat today. No,
>> a 17-year-old girl who was sending 17-year-old videos
back.
Uh, but I don't know what your [__] evidence is.
We already knew Rose was a young girl. We I don't know what your
evidence is. Uh, did Destin literally do that? Hold on. The fun
thing is I didn't solicit this person and her boyfriend record
a ton of stuff. The guy was literally trafficking her if that
what KF says is true. But again, no one really cares about it.
It's all memes, I guess. Wait, how does he know that? How does
he know that they were? How does he know that they did? He was
he able to obtain some of these things? Dude, my evidence would
be Destiny again for some reason. Has Destiny ever sent Rose's
videos around to anybody? I have no idea. Didn't seem to be a
part of his thing, right? Seemed like mostly if he sent videos
of other people, they included him seemingly. I don't I don't
know if there's evidence of him sending nudes of other people
by themselves. Check his logs. He asked for more. Yeah, I I'm
positive he asked for like uh he asked for stuff. Yeah. said,
"I never solicited her." Does that mean he never paid her or
does he mean solicit ask her for anything? Because he's definitely
asked her for stuff. Wait, what is this? H3H3 talked about Destiny
today. In what context? Hold on. We'll we'll take a quick break.
>> He says the Ethan Klein, Hassan [__] Destiny
situation is crazy. And I was like, Destiny? What does the does
Destiny have to do with it? I have >> He's business partners
with your sponsor. He's business partners with the guy who like
basically gives you the information for all your scripts which
are basically like combed through uh sorry basically built by
people who comb through Hassan's VODs which are
which are all DJs. All of those people are DJs. That's what it
has to do. What do >> you do with that? I don't know him.
I don't talk to him. I don't know what the [__] he's
up to.
Wait, this is like, dude, I'm trying to think of like famous.
This is like I spend, you know, every Sunday night getting playing
poker with uh Jean Cisco and and I like somebody asked me about
Eert. I'm like, I've never met Eert. I have no idea about that
guy. Right.
Like, dude, you you know two parts of like a duo. Sorry, you
know one part of a duo. I feel like you know the other part.
Did Dan and Co respond? Not yet. Not yet. Not yet. I don't know.
I think it's crazy for him to go like, I have no idea who Destiny
is. You fight Desty's enemies. You're on the same side as you
you literally converse all the time with his his best friend
and business partner. You have his best friend's like business's
logo there. You can't say you have nothing to do with him. Obviously,
you have connections to Destiny.
Obviously. Oh, PhyD covered the death threat thing and included
Destiny and Ethan is upset. >> Why do I care about what
Destiny is doing, Philip DeFranco? What are you talking about?
So, anyway, but he puts me and Hassan in the thumbnail and um
then he I don't know what it is. Wow. The disrespect. >> Did
he change it? What's currently?
He did an AB test between the two >> and he picked one.
>> Which one won?
>> The Destiny. >> A little E HD. Okay. It's Little
E HD.
>> Hassan. Destiny. Ethan. >> Hassan. Destiny. Ethan.
Hassan. Destiny.
>> The one without you. >> I still have the one with
you in it though, so it must be still. >> Let me go incognito.
Phillip Franco.
>> No way. No way he's that insecure. That's crazy. >> Let's
get to the bottom. Dropping this. Thank you for the gift earlier.
Sorry, son. This is what I'm saying. This is an intentional snub.
He's watching and he knows. I think he's
>> Doing this to intentionally be provocative and and just
plain rude to
>> I think I think Ethan's doing a bit here. I think Ethan's
doing a bit, but it's not. It's like a bit in the way Darius
is doing a bit. It's a bit in the way Darius is asking for a
phone number and knowing that he might get rejected, but he also
is like actually seething about being rejected. Okay, whatever.
It applies to Ethan. Okay, we know. >> I don't even know
what >> I don't know what part of it you're talking about.
The thumbnail. >> Philip DeFranco is a Hassan writer. >> I
don't know about that. In fact, I didn't see his reaction. I
heard Hassan was very upset by this video. >> I was too.
That's just because sounds like he's doing his job. >> Because
Hassan's a crybaby boy. and you'll see what I'm talking about,
okay? Like he he has to Anyway, so he took me out of the thumbnail,
but it's called the Ethan Klein Hassan [__] Destiny
situation is crazy. >> I already got when I saw that title,
>> Because it is not an Ethan Klein Hassan [__]
Destiny situation,
>> No, it is. Destiny literally said Hassan should be He
actually oneuped both of you guys. Listen, in terms of getting
unhinged in any given situation, getting like take it to a place
where everybody goes, "Whoa, settle down, brother." Uh, Destiny's
better than you guys, okay? In terms of getting like totally
crazy with, yeah, he's probably a little better than both you
guys and Hassan. They're like, "Oh, Hassan like they went over
the top. Hassan threatened my wife." And Hassan's like, "Yeah,
I guess Ela could have been targeted on that night raid." And
Ethan's like, "Oh, I guess I guess Hassan targeted my wife."
And he's like, "Hassan should die. Hassan should be right now."
>> Uh-huh. Okay. All right. >> It's not >> the
only reason to bring Destiny into it is to turn Hassan into a
sympathetic character. This >> uh he he he is unfortunately
Destiny made himself. >> That thing is about him
trying to get Ela which by the way >> nope he didn't do
that. >> His response is doubling down on him trying to
mark Ela as he's >> that's not true. That's a lie. We watched
him say, "Obviously, I don't think Ela's a valid target, so this
is just a lie." >> Like, she she was a valid military target.
She escaped justice.
You know, she could have been she should have been then. That
would have been fine. She escaped justice. You know, she's a
>> which is >> she committed a crime. She's a criminal.
>> He's wrong with everything that he said. >> Yeah.
I don't even think it was illegal. >> I don't >> Okay,
sorry. Uh, as much as this is cool, if you guys have other clips
of him seething about stuff, it's fine. But I'm going to go back
to the uh counterpoint stuff. So, >> we've already commented
on the fact that creating and distributing >> counter is
stupid. Uh I think we've also commented on the fact that sending
it to very young girls is stupid. Um and I don't think that definitionally
makes you a
makes you stupid. Um I I don't think it makes you a So, I hope
I hope I hope you got your you missed him calling Destiny an
idiot. Uh, >> Ryan Cougler,
>> I hope that helps you.
>> is that all Destiny did? He He sent some videos to this
young girl. Is that all? Is that all he did? Bro,
Connor just be leaving stuff out, man. >> There's only
40 million people. It's half the size of the millennials. >> Sure.
So, to this, I would basically say I agree that there has been
a lot of cons that have >> Gippy says he sent received.
Okay. Well, I need to see the evidence, but
uh you know, >> dude, every time these people come out
and defend him, whether it's Aerodite, whether it's Connor, whether
it's Willy Mack, Destiny can immediately show up and just cut
your legs out, right? Like he'll immediately come out and say,
"No, obviously I received her and her boyfriend recording a ton
of stuff, right? Obviously,
obviously he'll come out and say that." Oh, Connor Connor came
out and defended me. Well, let me go humiliate him real quick.
Let me go prove to him that he's a complete for trusting me.
Okay. Conor's like, I don't know. I think you see the evidence
he receives stuff. Destiny comes in. He's like, "I received a
ton of from that minor. I received a ton." It's like, "Brother,
why?" Connor just Connor was just defending you. He was literally
just defending you. What are you doing, dude? It is with precision,
Ozul. It is with precision every time that he comes in and just
cuts people's legs out. I don't know if is that the fetish like
he's going to get people to defend him and then he's going to
humiliate them by make them being making them look
every time. It's like wild to me that he can do this over and
over and over again. >> Good. Good for you. I guess >> have
come with giving women agency. I think giving women agency is
actually like a deonttological good. >> Ryan, there's Connor
on food shops entering the orbit. Uh she needs to stop looking
at lollycon. That's my thoughts. >> Letting people choose
means that they have the choice to choose the noble things. This
is really really important in Western society specifically. This
is the foundation of what we believe in the American project.
And so yes, women >> Gen X I'm actually specifically aware
of food shops because
uh probably two years ago may maybe two years ago
which is funny because Queean is, you know, I'm suspecting that
a substantive amount of these people are a part of
KF or Quean or Chud or Spicy Chat. though, weirdly enough, they
probably swim in the same waters as Quean, right? >> And
soqman
popularized food shops by covering her content repeatedly. >> There's
no way he can soy
food shops retired because she couldn't do anything. The only
lease on life food shops has ever gotten is trying to a log my
content for DG. That's the only lease on life she's gotten. What
are we talking about here, Connor? Quimman Quimman her career
and then Destiny resurrected it. Quimman it Destiny resurrected
it. This is already an insane place to start from because food
shops would defend the fact that she looked at Lollcon and that
became normalized in Chudlogic server and in Chudlogic's community
and I actually went on to stream with Chudlogic and I said, "Hey,
>> it didn't become normalized in Chudlogic's community.
They had a local on stream like three times. They had a local
on stream like three times. Connor, you literally hang out with
Destiny. I brother
who just raided food shops again tonight by the way. How could
he have any heat for this? Destiny raided food shops while food
chops was reacting to his minor son's debate with Drew Pavlu.
How is Connor How is his spine this flexible? How does the spine
just bend like this? How does it bend and warp around like this?
How can you not be embarrassed when you do this? >> I think
your community is filled with a bunch of crypto and you should
call this out
because effectively via Queenman
uh via the normalization of food shops and also your relationship
with Mr. Girl. >> Connor has to be just totally unaware
of the food shop, right? I I
dude there's no there's no way, right? I please tell me in this
VOD I get to watch somebody point out that Desi's raided food
shops like three times in the past week and has been on her stream.
Please tell me somebody points it out. So things like like Queen
and Chloic never did at all.
I think there's a a bunch of a feeopile and apologist swimming
around in your community and uh Chud and I actually thought about
that a little bit because he's like it's not my responsibility
these people, you know, why are you heranging me about stupid
[__] my chat's doing? He was kind of defensive about
it right now. Now, I got accused of being a hypocrite because
Vosch almost within like a month or two months. Uh Vosch was
caught having Lollcon on his folder and he
was working with Pave and I was also working with Pave and I
was brought on by Chudlo Logic and Queen and other people and
they're like, "Oh, you had all this heat for food shops. You
had all this heat for the Aphibiles and in this community." And
yet when Vosch is revealed to be an aphibilic horse enjoyer,
you got no heat for him. And I just said, we're working together
on a project. We're we're trying to bring something into the
real world. And so as a result, I think everybody knows my opinion
on this.
Yeah, but when you say hold on, all he's saying right now is
my principles don't actually exist. that when it becomes hard
to keep to hold my principles, when it becomes difficult to stand
on business with with regards to my values and my principles,
I fold every time. That's what he's saying. Like, why should
I listen to you speak if you literally cannot stand on business
on anything? He did
conservative stood on business to campus for Democrats. Yes,
but I'm not going to make like a takeown video or a hit piece
or whatever on Bosch. You guys can go [__] yourselves.
and I took some level of flak for it, but I think ultimately
everybody understood my position and they were a bunch of moral
frogs.
Um, they were a bunch of moral frogs similar to what we're experiencing
today. What's funny about this is we had a fee files who were
talking about Lolita earlier today and effectively like we we
fought them and we banned three or four of >> I wonder
where they came from. >> Right.
And uh that that's how we spent our time earlier. But now, uh,
the people who are in our chat right now,
>> Connor has a non- internet life. Oh, somebody Wait,
I doubt he's even aware of food shops. Hold on. I'm not showing
the chat. I don't think the chat catches up anyway, but me. >> Oh,
Destiny did this bad thing. Aren't you going to disavow now?
Aren't you going to do Aren't you going to do this now? Aren't
you going to do this now? Aren't you going to do this now? And
no offense, guys, but like when there's a dozen of you throughout
the day. >> Oh, thoughts on food shops entering the orbit.
Oh god, it's going to get there. It's going to get there. >> It
doesn't feel like an organic concern
from somebody in my community who's saying, "Hey, actually Steven
did this thing. Isn't that crazy? You should disavow him." It
feels like what happened was you guys got some piece of information
on KF. I'll I'll take a look at it later when the drama coverage
covers it. And you're running to everyone who's ever associated
with Steven ever. And you're trying to socially isolate him by
destroying all of his relationships.
That's what it feels like. And I'm just going to say, uh, Steve
socially isolate him by destroying all of his
H, I don't think so. I think Connor gets way less heat than some
people because he just comes out and says like, uh, and by the
way, Dusty's doing that, but like I think it's more just like,
dude, don't sweep. Don't say he's not doing what he's doing.
When Connor comes out at the beginning of the stream and says
like, yeah, what? Yeah, he's he's minor. He's like soliciting
CESAM
problem. When he does that, I guess it's like pretty hard to
he's kind of just on he's standing on business there. It's weird
that his principles to stand by destiny hold up more than his
any of his other principles in his life, including the normalizing
or he actually cares more about standing by destiny than normalizing.
Couldn't have possibly predicted that to be honest based on his
conservative leanings. I could never have predicted that. But
yeah, it's um dude, that's actually I say these things and I'm
like I sit back and I'm like, dude, that's f that's wild. But
that's actually what it is somehow. >> I've acknowledged
that Steven has done or is alleged to have done. I've acknowledged
that a lot of people view him as a bad guy. And I've said there's
a chance that he could be a serial killer. Well, guess what?
At this point, I'm not just somebody who u I don't know. I'm
not just somebody who collaborates with Steven on occasion. I'm
somebody who I I think Stephen and I have hung out enough in
in real life in order to call each other friends. Uh so if he's
a serial killer, I'll visit him in prison. And you can say, "Hey,
isn't it bad that you're friends with a serial killer?" And I'll
go, "Yeah, it's you know, killing people is bad." You know what
do you want me
to say? Yes.
And eating people is bad. Hannibal Lectar is bad. What do you
want me to say? or Trump. There's there's a dank cheeto in the
White House, bro. What do you want me to say? There's a there's
a dank cheeto in the White House.
Making homemade distributing it recklessly is bad, but I'll go
visit him in prison. You know, I'll put 20 bucks in his commissary
so he can buy honey buns, you know, just so uh prison is tolerable.
Is what it is. So, sorry uh sorry if you want more, but that's
what I got for you. And by the way, same thing goes for Chud
Logic. Um, you know, Chud and I, uh, we're not as friendly as
we used to be, but if Chud, let's say Chud,
he had, Dude, he's about to do the Tommy C thing. Chud, if I
found out you were a I would still ride with you, okay? I'd look
the other way.
If I found out you were a I'd look the other way, Chud, okay.
I I looked the other way once when I thought you were a and I'd
look the other way again if I thought thought you were in the
future >> drama where a woman lied to him about her age
and he was a called call the for a few months. Um I'm friendly
enough with Chud that if if Chud went to prison for being a serial
killer uh I would visit him a couple of times and I would put
$20 in his commissary so he could get honey buns,
you know.
>> back then you didn't have as many choices. They couldn't
own >> I'm just going to say it, guys. I'm just going to
say it. You ever find out anything like that about me, okay?
That I'm like soliciting C7, dude. If you find out anything like
that, feel free to just say like this guy forever,
okay? Will never happen. Will never happen. But if it does, feel
free to just say this guy. I'm not going to come see you in prison,
okay? I feel like that's a better world where we know he's going
to be shamed. I could have sworn Connor understood this. or Connor
had thought about this in the past, but maybe not. Maybe now
Connor's just like, you know,
I'm down with Destiny and food shops.
Um
maybe no Panda Rider cuz uh some of those things are memes and
some of those things are serious.
I'm serious about this one. >> Private property I with
the E dating thing that was more me making fun of the Eaters
in my server. Okay. >> Basically had to be married to a
man to have any access or rights or power. >> They couldn't
have a credit card till the '8s. >> Wait, I missed the
chat. basically had to be married to a man to have any >> Man,
KF haters are going to be so bummed when Pixie loses her case.
Wait, every KF hater understands that Pixie's case is is like
going to be difficult. There's not a single person, dude. So
many of these people say that I'm like I told people Desi is
definitely going to lose his case. Tell me anywhere where I said
that he was like definitely losing his pixie case. I feel like
there might have been some like I feel like I was always going
well there's kind of an argument here, you know? I think this
is like a strong argument for the Cardi stuff. I said if he can
prove it, if he can find it within the days, right, then I'm
I'm pretty sure he can get the Cardi claim through. The Cardi
claim seems like kind of on its face proven. Or if the the the
what do you continuous publishing thing goes through? Either
one of those. >> Her rights are power. >> They couldn't
have a credit card till the '8s. >> Exactly. Right. So
women had
women had less agency. Women had less agency. But I would argue
that that was a moral failing of society. And just because the
outcomes right now might be worse, that doesn't necessarily mean
that this is not something that we fundamentally value. We value
in America giving people choice. >> I hear that. I remember,
you know, last week we had this big debate on police. And uh
I think the shortcomings for Michael Malice, which I respect
the guy, he's a good friend, but he kept saying police were bad.
And it sounded like all he was saying was yes, there are big
problems with police and there's no alternative or >> skipping
past all these brooms. Can we get some sweeping in the chat for
Connor? Can we get some sweeping? Sorry, we're getting one guide
again, but I'm very tired, so I don't have the I don't have the
rage I can normal normally sum uh um summon for it. Harvey my
says, "I think this is why you're the sweeper emo." Uh broom
broom broom. But here's the thing, Harvey My engagement
earnestly. Sweeping. >> Yeah, I think Connor doesn't know
how the thing works and he just is letting it auto go through
all of his chats so they all pop up. >> It means you're
sweeping the problem under the rugg, right? It it means that
you don't acknowledge that there's a
>> No, it can be minimizing the problem. That is also sweeping.
Sweeping is also minimizing the problem. It's not just pretending
it didn't happen. It's minimizing it. Like going, "Yeah, so she
was 17. I knew that a year ago. What's the big deal?" That's
sweeping, bro. The problem's there. The problem is acknowledged.
You're criticizing the problem. What you're saying though, realistically,
is you can't associate with this human being anymore because
they engage in bad behavior and I'm telling you to go yourself,
right? That's where we're at. You're saying, "Oh, like for instance,
Gabe Utsick says, "Just admit you twist your morals for whatever
benefits yourself." No, I don't. I've been I've been married
to the same woman for 13 years. I've never
emotionally
or physically cheated on my spouse ever. I've never created
>> Yeah. So, I'd say I but I don't trust you. Why would
I trust you? I think the reason you haven't cheated on your spouse
is cuz the right opportunity hasn't come along. All evidence
I see and know about Connor suggests that none of your principles
will you stand on. That's what that's what everything I've seen
about you says to me. So, like whatever the whatever the [__]
you're talking about here where you're like, "Oh, I've never
cheated on my wife." I think that's just cuz you haven't Desi
hasn't offered to suck your dick yet. That's basically it. Okay?
>> And spreaded it to other people. I've never done any
of these things and I think these things are bad behavior and
I've criticized these bad behaviors openly.
So please I've also never
this is uh this is Destiny's
Boomer Sweeper Auggie. That's who this is. Destiny's Boomer Sweeper
comes in basically open his stream up. All right. I don't know
if you just saw what I retweeted on Twitter. You can watch the
opening comments from his stream. He basically rolled and was
like, "Yeah, Dusty was 17year-old, but I knew that a year ago.
I don't care. It's like, okay. All right. That's weird. Just
giga chatting cam collection, I guess. Yeah, he collected cam.
Gigachad.
>> Ever looked at >> horses engaged with teenagers.
I've also never flirted with 17year-olds on Discord. Chad might
be catching a stray with that one, but you >> That's not
what Destiny did. He didn't just flirt with this person. What
do we do? Connor. Connor. He went to an age a non-ageverified
platform,
initiated contact with somebody he knew is young, right? Or was
contacted by her possibly. Maybe maybe he was contacted by her,
but I thought he said he'd gone to like buy nudes off of Twitter.
Okay.
Did you just say before the propaganda gets created is so funny.
I know. I know that the people who try to talk a lot of people
like Erodite's smart. Okay. Arrodite knows after the original
Turkey Tob interview, she's just like, I'm going to keep my head
down until Destiny tells me what to say. All right, I'm gonna
keep my head down. Yeah, Auggie knows, man. Before the narrative
sets in, dude. Oh, but that's just politics, isn't it? That's
how politicians are, too. When a big scandal pops up, you catch
a politician off guard when they don't have their talking points
yet, either. They don't know their spin, and they're just like
a deer in the headlights. That's what Connor is right now. It's
so >> You know, I I have to presume that some of you guys
are within that community as well. So, so anyways, my my point
to you is show me the immoral behavior that I've engaged in,
Gabe. Because what you're doing is you're saying that continuing
to associate with a person who may have engaged in bad behavior.
>> I thought Wait, earlier he said he knew that a year
ago that he was with a
I thought you were just saying you weren't denying it, but now
you are denying it. >> That's all you're doing. You just
want me to disassociate.
>> That's all you want me to do. >> The system will
No, I want So I'm not going to anybody. I never have gone I've
never once gone to Wes by the way and gone Wes you have to you
have to disassociate you have to disavow Destiny Wes because
Wes came on two days after all that news dropped and went yeah
Destiny's a freak Destiny's a total psychopath freak I knew he
could do this from the first second I met him and I'm friends
with him anyway cuz he's funny so [__] it I don't
care right that's what Wes said and Wes has never stated any
preference or any principle to to conflict with that Wes has
always been on that where he's like yeah I'm immoral yeah I'm
a degenerate yeah I roll with other people who do Right. And
I never once pressed this guy and he's been on my stream multiple
times since. Never once pressed this guy to to disavow Destiny,
walk away from Destiny. Right. The problem is Connors specified
a principle against
normalizing lollycon, normalizing anything adjacent, right? And
uh having a principle against doxing, having he's he's specified
multiple principles that he's changed entirely for Destiny's
sake. That's why people are pressing you. Okay? Nobody's pressing
you because they just want Destiny isolated. They're pressing
you because you stated certain principles that you will not live
up to because you know it's monetarily beneficial to you to not
do that. Oh, that's the thing that actually prevents Connor.
If somebody offered Connor like 50 grand to cheat on his wife,
he would do it 100%. 100%. >> Will always be bad in some
way, but there is a worse. Oh, I'm used to seeing Destiny hanging
around here. Where is he tonight? I don't know what he's doing
tonight, man. Uh he's he's running magnets over his hard drives
right now, Augie. He he needs some time. Okay, >> so I
look at this now and I'm like, okay, you know, I agree to to
a certain degree theological aspect of people should have free
choice. You want have a job, you can do it. You want to have
finances, all that's fine. Is the end result then? >> Cool.
Doggo says it's weird to have this meta conversation instead
of just owning that you don't care that he kids. has Steven children.
>> The Gen Alpha is 40 million and collapsing and there
won't be any humans in the future or cities are going to start
shrinking, infrastructure is going to start crumbling and we're
going to go, you know, it was a moral good to make sure that
we had this semblance of equality under the law and then society
>> uh No, cuz apparently she had good parents who wouldn't
let her fly to Miami. But that's the only reason that it didn't
happen cuz her parents said, "No, no, no. You can't fly to Miami.
You no, you're not allowed." >> Destroyed by it. Well,
equity of agency does mean bad outcomes sometimes. The issue
is that I'm not opposed to people >> which proves that
when women have agency, things go bad. >> Actually, when
most people have agency, people make terrible choices, right?
When we give young men free agency, what's the window where young
men do the most crime? It's typically the areas.
>> Buckeye says, "Hey, Connor just got here. Did you see
that Queenman raided Pisco?" No, but I'm not surprised, right?
He he likes Pisco the most out of the Lib and Learn crew. ages
where they get the most amount of agency. People when they are
>> Oh, did you hear that? It's very concerning this. Do
you see how this is raiding? Do you see what he was doing? He's
like trying to shape opinions from the shadows. Okay. Very concerning.
I need to update you on this. >> Given choice often choose
poorly, but that's not the reason we don't give them choice.
Because if we don't give them choice, they are enslaved to correct
action because of necess. >> Oh, it's it's Richie. It's
Richie. Look, it's Richie.
Maybe you should just talk to him about getting help or therapy
regarding this is all. If you are his friend, maybe you should
set a boundary on what that friendship can take. >> Richie.
Richie. Nice guy. Wity. And that's not the world that we want
to live in. We want people to choose the noble thing because
they are choosing to do something. >> Now, here's the thing.
Wait, wait, wait. I see your perspective with agency. I I see
that. But we need to be honest with women. The problem is that
we're not honest with women, right? We don't tell them, "Look,
if you want to pursue a >> Oh, hold on. Somebody is pointing
something very funny out to me. Okay.
Some somehow Connor, you know, did a plus or minus one on the
age here. Okay. Couple weeks ago. For some reason >> 3
months ago, 3 months ago, here's what Connor was saying about
Rose's age. >> Thought that it was okay to DM this 19year-old
or 18year-old Only Fans girl on Twitter.
Oh, apparently he might not have known this a year ago cuz here
he is saying 18-year-old 19-year-old while he's reviewing the
Willie Mac Show Content Cop on Destiny. So, she's 18 or 19 3
months ago, May 11th, 2025. >> Why? What are you achieving?
You're not having children. You're not having children with any
of these people. Uh
>> Uh-huh. You're not having children. Okay. And then in
the same video, this is the same video. >> Some OCD. Oh,
this is 6 months ago. 6 months ago when he's talking about >> And
then he was also a 19-year-old Only Fans model who I think was
name Okay. So 6 months ago, he also
thought she was 18 or 19. 19. He says here, then it's 18 or 19
and now it's like, yeah, I knew she was 17 or 18 like a year
ago. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Wow. Something changed. I don't know what changed
cuz apparently he knew she was 17 the whole
>> You want to make money? Your chance of >> Wait,
so Connor knew she was 17 the whole time and said she was 19,
so he literally helped cover it up. No, he's obviously just lying
now. But that is a funnier way to put it. Yes, he's obviously
just lying now. He did not know this. He He keeps pretty tapped
into the drama. People are like, "Oh, Connor doesn't really keep
plugged in, brother." He went on Chudlo Logic stream and knew
every single crazy thing food shops did. Okay, this guy's tapped
in. He's connected. He knows all of the drama that's going on.
Let's not Let's not fake it. Let's not >> finding a guy
down the road are going to be significantly harder. We don't
tell them if you decide to be promiscuous now is going to cost
you. >> Oh, guys, no offense, but I don't mind. Sorry for
ying in your ears. I don't mind contending with my schizophrenics.
So, I don't know if you guys already I don't know if the wrench
has already got all the kiwi farmers, but you know, good luck
kiwi far. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Hold on.
Uh,
we got more more comments. Hold on. Destiny Destiny is analyzing
the um
Destiny's analyzing the the the proof as we speak. Hold on. Was
there any Wait, was there any proof that of her being underage
besides that ticket? Why isn't this box checked? Uh, I'm guessing
if we look at the date of that ticket. Hold on. I'm wondering
if we look at that ticket. Let me go find it somewhere. Was she
Was she under How old was she when she got the ticket? I actually
have to look. Uh, Queen and Yellow posted this redacted. I'll
see if I can pull it up on stream. I'll see if this is okay to
pull up on stream. I'm not totally sure. Give me a second. I'm
looking. I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm looking.
I'm looking. I'm looking. Where did they post this? Where did
they post this? Right here. They might be young in that, but
I don't know. The I don't think there's any way you could show
H
nothing. Oh, did you say I guess it's not impossible? Hold on.
Oh, why does this box say? Yes, but I've never seen Dob written
in my entire life as just two digits like that on any government
thing. I guess it's not impossible. Oh, wait. The ticket could
come from later, I guess. Never mind. Oh, no. Wait, no, because
the last payment for the ticket was 2021.
I mean, this doesn't sound like a guy who thought he had like
sure as proof that this girl was
right. Right. Am I crazy that he's spending a bunch of time looking
into this right now? It seems a little rough.
and or spicy chatters. >> Okay, now hold on. I think what
Rey was saying was important, but I do have to point out that
what Rei was saying did seem to have like it felt like to a lot
of people it felt like defending Destiny. I don't think he was
doing that. Okay. But some people felt like that and Destiny
had to come in and go like, "No, I have no confidence that she
was 18. I have no confidence that she was 18 actually." Oh no.
Yeah. [__] you, Kathy. I'm not I'm not putting a
log on screen that involves you. [__] >> and
or whoever. But I caught up with >> Stop being so selfobsessed,
Kathy. Okay, stop being so selfobsessed. You're >> Speaking
of which, like the stream, share it with your friends. Engage
with chat. Super chats if you got them. Memberships if you got
them. My pair of socially love you. >> And if Grass Tedon
or Gen X, if they end up being serial killers, I'll visit them
in prison as well. Code says, "Don't yawn too much, Connor. I'm
at work and I need you to keep talking to my ear." I'm sorry.
I came back. It was the same >> we got. We got one more.
One more right >> A Kiwi farmer who >> dude some
of these cut in like in the middle of the little rant here. >> As
he was saying this might lead to >> the house being Yeah.
>> So let me give an example. You guys are familiar with
Jordan Peterson Bill C16. He was super worried about um Are you
guys familiar with this? So I don't have to like summarize it.
You guys are familiar about this? >> Great. Okay. >> Yeah.
He lost that, didn't he? >> He did. But one of his arguments
for why he's doing it is he was saying this might lead to some
sort of a >> Oh, I see. Tequila Suns said the page that
shows her DOB is from the party detail as in her personal profile
in their database. So it wouldn't mark juvenile since she's not
a minor anymore. That's separate from the specific listing for
the traffic ticket. Gotcha. So no longer >> territorian
control on free speech. And a whole bunch of people like especially
on my side are like you're so stupid. The issue is that it is
very likely that his advocacy against C-16 is part of what informed
Congress's interpretation of that bill to make it. All >> right,
back this up. We're going to we're going to get on to something
here in just a second. >> Issue with you guys saying women
should be more cautious. Women aren't being very smart.
>> somehow they just started saying it, right? People acting
like this is new information. We always knew her age. Keep trying
cafers. That's the new cope. Guys, we already swept this. We
already knew she was 17. We already knew she was a minor, guys.
We already We all already Didn't you guys know she was a minor?
Didn't you guys know Destiny was getting Cam? Didn't you know
Destiny was like totally collecting CP? We all knew that. We're
all standing by him. Anyway, this is old news, guys. We've been
talking about this for a year now. We've been talking about how
this guy's been for a year now. Can we get over that? There's
a dang cheeto in the White House.
There's a dang cheeto in the White House. Are you Aren't you
all about stopping Trump? Are you going to let fascism take over
your country? Stop focusing on the fact that Destiny 17-year-old.
Okay. Oh, the amount of things I wish I could tell everyone right
now. There are some things out there. There are like some things
out there that are pretty [__] annoying about this
guy that
can't be said, but they will be said. >> Come to 230p on
Monday through Friday. I hang out with the counterpoint chat.
And >> Whoa, whoa, whoa. Is Destiny cool? Whoops. This
is the wrong clip as well. Is Destiny cool with him saying this
considering that's not what he is saying? Uh, I don't know. I
don't know. Row in the replies. Ralph's everywhere. Okay. Doomer
Media >> going to be back into the routine. >> Whoops.
I I lost it. Hold on. Let me get Let me grab that pixie tweet
again real quick. Pixie is vague posting. Pixie is vague posting.
Doomer media. I think we got that within seconds, right? Yeah.
1 minute. You can tell me. Do not tell. Well, actually, Mal is
pretty trustworthy, but you wouldn't believe that. Okay. You
might not believe that. Mal's pretty trustworthy.
What secrets is she harboring? I don't know that I have like
that much. I would just wait. I
there's nothing I trust me I don't have anything on the order
of Rose is actually a minor. I don't have anything on that order.
Okay, we're we're dealing with like the big the big news that
dropped today. I don't want to I don't want to taint it with
anything. Okay, >> women should be more cautious. Women
aren't being very smart. I I don't have >> true an issue
with that. That's free speech and that is some of the things
that will probably offset the degradation of society that you're
maybe worried about if I agree with your like worldview. What
I care about >> Wait, wait, wait. Hold on. She's got one
response you missed. What do you mean? Hold up. What do you mean
one response you missed? He knew. Oh, the amount of things. There's
a reply that I missed. Find it funny. No, no, no, no, no, there
isn't. What do you mean there's a response that I missed? You
talking about the morale one? Oh, a new comment that you're
Oh, it's from somebody I blocked. You're raped. You're raped.
I don't see it cuz you're blocked or ignored by me. You lost.
Jesus Christ, dude. What if I was on Twitch?
What if it's on Twitch right now? What the That's crazy, dude.
What the hell? I was so focused on the pixie tweet that I didn't
see what was clearly right in front of my face. That's not my
fa That's not my feed. That's not my feed. That's I don't know
why that popped up. >> It's taking away rights. That's
it. That's my hard line. Don't take away. Let me ask you the
question. If >> only what happened. Don't worry, buddy.
That's not my That's not my algorithm. No. Shut up. Shut up.
Shut up. >> Reasonable for the internet. you have described
leads to the end of humanity. Was it a good system? >> I
I would have to >> uh no obviously >> believe you
that the uh American project will lead to the end of society.
I just don't think it will. >> The question is let's try
this again. >> If a system >> in a hypothetical sense,
sure >> of open and free choice would ultimately would
ultimately lead to the end of the of civilization, human death
and is it a good system?
>> You're curious because he said he told you in DMs to
ask Jesse for proof about doxing. I don't think that's we have
so at what >> Jeffrey Engel says, "I was just curious because
he said he told you in DMs to ask Ethne for proof about the doxing
claims." Yeah. And then um Steven actually didn't provide me
the proof for the doxing claims. It was somebody else. Uh but
I don't know if I have it. Let Let me see if I have it. I might
have it. Give me one second. I'm actually going to look it up.
I remember it starts with a C. You guys might know what I'm talking
about. Um, but there was effectively a dude who was ping around
in the
spicy chat discord and I think >> Oh,
is he talking He I know who he's talking about. >> Think
the Queenman Discord. I don't know when the Queen Discord was
created, but there was. >> Dude, there's no way that he's
talking about Courtfire right now. He's talking about Courtfire.
effectively a dude with a C and he was supposed to be like a
big Kiwi farmer who loved to [__] dox
>> and
um he was paling around. He got he got banned because he actually
did dox someone. Um >> by the way Corfire literally had
never sent a message in my server. I knew who he was. I banned
him immediately.
Uh sorry Corfire. Don't dox me please. >> He he doxed
>> or could you even be worse than Destiny and Dan? I don't
think so. He docked somebody in the community and he was crowing
about it and then he did get banned but then he came back on
a different it was the same PFP different name and then he was
ping around for a while and I don't know if he got banned again.
So again, like I'm not even >> Connor is just like not
really knowing and and reging. And
dude, if Corfire is your only proof, then if Corfire is your
only proof and Spencer's the only other proof, then why the are
these people focused on me and Quimman and not Chud. Not to throw
Chud under the bus, but that's all spicy chat. Okay, that's all.
And spicy chat does ban these people. So like basically immediately,
I don't believe that Courtfire came back and was welcomed. Courtfire
was persona nongrada there. Okay. How does that explain why you're
going after Queen or me if it's courtfire? That's crazy. >> Appealing
to some like nefarious
thing, right? Like I'm not even saying that it's like, oh, you
know, Queman and and JTO are so evil. They're knowingly covering
up for whatever.
I'm just saying that that's where the suspicion
that KF
crosspollinates with Jtock,
Spicy Chat, and Quean. That's where that accusation came from.
>> That is totally that's like obviously.
>> So I I don't know how things can change within a few
years. So I don't know how true it is. I'm just telling you the
evidence that was presented to me that was supposed to support
that narrative.
And so if they're dude, if I come along and say like somebody's
a and they ask somebody asked me for proof and it's like well
there's like a in their neighborhood once like 10 years ago,
are you are you not going to go oh that guy is a weirdo loser
for lying to me and trying to denigrate or trying to like smear
that other person? You're just going to go well you know I don't
know how much truth there is there. I'm just going to like kind
of question whether or not this guy's a for a while. That's all.
Where again where are the morals? Where are the principles? Where
is anything? Where is this guy's spine? Where's the spine, Connor?
Where's the
Oh, look. It's a It's a totally disingenuous lie from Christian
Valeris mod in Connor's chat. Given Rose was an Only Fans model
and had a Twitter account specific to hosting/selling nudes.
She is not a minor. Wrong. That is an overt lie. In fact, if
she was an Only Fans model, I think you would lose a lot of the
criticism that you could have for Destiny cuz she would be on
a on a on an age verified platform selling stuff, right? And
he would have every reason to believe she was of age. But actually,
that isn't the case. And all we've gotten along those lines is
Destiny lying and saying, "Well, she was on Tinder and I think
Tinder age verified. It didn't age verify. Definitely not in
her state. Okay. Definitely not in 2021 or 2022 when she would
have been on it. Okay. It it definitely didn't. So, I don't know
what this cope is that she was on any age verified platform that
Destiny would have been aware of. She was not. There's a bunch
of gay ops. I don't do gay ops, right? So, I'm not interested.
I I'll give my opinion. Um, but but so, so for instance, hold
on. Let's let's make this point, though. Christian Blair says,
"Given Rose was an Only Fans model and had a Twitter account
specific to hosting, selling her nudes, she is not a minor."
Okay, here's the thing. I think that if you see a >> is
he gonna is he going to know enough? Does he just talk about
this and he doesn't even know that that's a lie?
bro, how how girl who is selling her nudes on the internet? You
could probably presume that she's engaging as an adult and if
she looks >> Connor just justified all child porn purchases
on the internet. Like literally, if that was the logic you could
go with, that is not a minor. Okay, here's the thing. I think
that if you see a girl who is selling her nudes on the internet,
you could probably presume that she's engaging as an adult. And
if she dude, dude, putting the CPA counterpoints like I assume
that this is too humiliating to continue. I assume that this
is just way too humiliating for these people to continue with.
This is This is crazy. This is like next level humiliation ritual
right now.
Absolutely next level humiliation ritual that I cannot fathom,
cannot understand, do not comprehend. I don't know how many other
ways I could say that, but it's >> It looks like an adult
Tested. It's insane to me that this vapid is vague posting about
stuff. She could say, "Well, fighting tooth and nail to keep
our transcript seal from the open court hearing." Holy wow.
Very hinged. Very cool. Very on the ball. Very not weird. very
not. Oh, that doesn't quite pop up on screen for you guys. I
think I need to like pop out the uh Oh, whoops. Oh, I'm hitting
buttons in OBS. I hope that didn't change
Are you guys Can you guys still hear me? I just hit some buttons
in OBS. I meant to do this like to pop out my uh here so that
I push these logs out for you.
Yeah, guys. All about the transcript. It's all about the It's
all about the transcript, guys. Soon as we get the transcript.
Soon as we get the transcript. Why is Ebony spazzing out? Well,
Evil Morty, if you didn't know, um, apparently we've gotten proof
today. I say apparently cuz I looked through it and I cannot
see like a flaw with it. Okay, I looked through it. I talked
to some people. I was like, "Oh, I think I see I I even was talking
to people. I was like, "Oh, maybe there's a flaw here." And then
I realized like more stuff got posted. I'm like, "Oh, no. That
seals that." Nope. Never mind. Right. So, apparently we've we've
seen it proven now that the Rose Girl is 17 or some girl Destiny
was posting about is 17. And but I don't even think that's the
case anymore. I'm referring to I think so what I think is the
case.
I don't want to say too much cuz it's hard to get into when somebody
is like um skeptical of it a little bit. Oh, whoops. I believe
you would have had to control her social media profiles
and the not safe for work Twitter account to have manipulated
this. And I don't think that's possible. What are you eating?
Um curry. Got a curry veggie dish. It's good. Real good. Finish
chewing. No, you can listen to me chew.
Oh no, Augie was right about the Indian feed. Oh me, she's probably
an adult. Let's continue. Oh, and her friend's IG. Yeah, >> however,
I don't think you should be consuming that content in the first
place. I don't think you should be engaging with a human being
like that. So, that's where for me, we're we're getting into
degrees of
Stevie is quote unquote a because he, you know, the definition
of a >> Hey, there's no way. No way. I just heard the definition.
There's no way that counterpoints Connor is about to walk in
here and give me a schooling on
if he file heafile.
That's not possible. There's no way that Connor is going to do
the actual like DGEN lefttoid meme. There's no way. There's no
chance that he's about to do that. I just hit pause to make a
totally different point and I heard him say the definition and
I I lost whatever point I was going to make cuz as I hit pause
I hear the definition come out of his mouth. There's no way.
Oh, I was about to say he's not he's not like a real in terms
of the definition. I was going to say he's like an internet where
we just say if you try to somebody under 17 or under 18 like
a right that's what it is but there's no way Connor is going
to do it right. I can understand Queman doing it. Queman is like
that kind of person. Okay. and he he'll defend all kinds of [__]
Connor is not that guy. Connor is the guy who comes in and so
out right about people who do that. Conor's the guy who's the
conservative who comes and goes, "It's really stupid that you
guys come in and say all this. Why would you Why would you muddy
the waters on this? Why would you Why would you obiscate?
That's that's who Connor is." So I don't understand how he can
come in and do this right now. That's what he's going to do.
There's no way >> because he you know the definition of
a somebody who has with kids. But then of course once you ask
the details that's not the definition of it would be a primary
attraction to prepubescent uh features a primary attraction as
in not like something you're also willing to accept but a primary
attraction to these things. You don't have to the kids to be
a of it. It's oh he engaged with somebody who was either 18 19
or 17 depending on who you ask selling stuff on the internet.
That's already bad. That's already bad enough, but it's not the
same as the original accusation. Mark says, "Does it change for
you at all, Connor, that in the leaks, one of the first messages
he said is
uh Connor points when he was talking to Chud is, I don't care
that the lolly didn't hurt a child. It's a principle. It's bad
in and of itself." I remember him saying this. Yes, that's why
it was so frustrating to hear the Vos, right? He's like, "Normalizing
is bad in and of itself." >> Is you look underage and he
didn't get an ID from her. I mean, that's obviously [__]
stupid. I would have to see that evidence. Like I I don't know.
You're just like a chatter. So I don't even know if that's true.
So yeah. Anyways, >> what point in the current trends would
it get bad enough for you to believe we are on track for civilizational
like fertility at.3 or 6. >> Uh no not no that's tough
because the fertility issue is way less about feminism and way
more about our terrible food and our agriculture. >> I
disagree. Well, like you guys just talked about and testosterone
like that's that's really bad for fertility. >> Well, you
know, they do say that that actually, you know, I was saying
that earlier about the microplastics, men are >> Gotcha.
So, Chatter and Spicy posted a doc years ago in there. So, Destiny
is doxing him now. Genuinely trying to understand the argument.
No, Destiny's not even doxing that guy. Destiny is saying because
that guy doxed somebody years ago and then got banned that anybody
who's ever interacted in that community can be doxed now. That's
what Destiny is saying. K. That's what Destiny is saying. Well,
you know, they do say that that actually, you know, I was saying
that earlier about the microplastics. Men are to blame for the
>> uh Yeah, Jeffrey Hle, I'll I'll draw you. You know,
I understand we're on different sides of this thing, but I'll
genuinely draw you a diagram momentarily. One second. >> Porter
Porter just came through with a link for me. Okay. What is this?
What is this? What is this?
>> Okay. Whatever the you want. You >> This is Connor
in that whole thing with uh this is Connor in the M cop argument.
So, how about this? How about Yeah, I conducted [__]
investigations. I conducted investigations into child abuse,
child
getting murdered, people getting their houses broken in. >> Oh,
well, it seems like wouldn't that be wouldn't that have given
him some empathy for those people and like a sething hatred for
people producing and or sharing those things or >> dude,
their cars broken into and on top of that animal abuse and [__]
child abuse. So, officially a [__] job. Yes, absolutely.
I took photographs. I took reports. I documented evidence. And
I got people convicted. I put more >> Oh god. Sherry and
straight made him see so badly in this conversation. >> I
put more pieces of [__] behind bars.
>> Wait, those people all be pieces of
people with child pieces of [__] Now >> you
Okay. Literally child. No, she literally you're >> the
guy who's getting mocked for soying about how he did child investigation
is the only person who's going to stick with this guy. There's
no way. There's just no way. Some evil spoiled.
>> Too bad you have all that experience and I left you
this conspiracy brain then. Jesus, Connor.
Because I'm making logical inferences that that are seriously
the equivalent of algebra. You guys are extraordinary and you
know it. This is Desty's boy, by the way. Or sorry, this is Conor's
boy who's just laughing at him getting mobed in this debate.
>> No, I don't. I don't need to see your
and die, you dumb [__]
>> Jeez, that seems a little rude.
>> Like, does it seem rude? Does it seem rude that if I
actually had like blood and gut? I don't think you're an investigator.
That's it. Look at you. >> What do you think, patrol? Okay.
All right. All right. Let's do this down. Yeah, let's chill this
out. Let's chill this out. So, what do you think? >> Now,
we're going to chill out after we're talking about what I can
do in my ass and to die.
>> that's up, dude. Well, hold on. Full of health. Okay,
>> now we're going to calm down.
>> Okay. He's conducted all of these investigations. Okay.
This was literally Cher's Cyine Chapel. Okay. Hold on. What is
this? I can't scope it out before I put it on stream. So, what
is it? Okay. What do you think patrolman do? >> We'll see.
>> He's not just the investigator. He's the >> I
don't know. Okay. Cherry's going to keep mogging this guy. Do
we just watch him like continue to mob Cherry totally >> the
regulator of Cher's ass? >> What? What do you No, no, no.
Let Let Cherry, what do you think patrolman do? >> I think
that's technically me now. I think I've actually got that title.
>> Depends. What are you patrolling the middle school?
>> Okay. What do you think regular street patrolman do?
>> You said you were patrolling the school.
>> for one year of my fouryear career, >> did you
use >> three years on the road? I had a segue. It was actually
super
>> That's so [__] brutal. Oh my god.
>> Oh, the Paul Blart segway. Let's go. >> On the
road for three years. >> My My total career was four years.
I spent one year in the school. I spent three years on the road.
What do you think cops do on the road?
>> I listen, I'm not a cop. Um, I'm >> Don't back
off of it. You had an you had an opinion on my professional.
Please tell me what you think that the opinions are. No, please
tell me. I I I am I am fascinated. I am I am focused on your
opinion of what law enforcement
do. >> I'm never forgetting what you just said,
>> Um,
if you're on the road, maybe you're pulling people over for traffic
>> Okay. That's a part of the job. What else do you think
they do? responding to
>> And what do you think they do after those calls? >> They
write reports. >> Connor, can you just get to the point
of what you did? >> No. I I want you to I want >> They
get drunk, baby. That's what they >> Tell Tell me what
law enforcement officers do after they go to a call. >> Get
donut. >> Can you believe I used to actually feel bad for
Connor as a as a function of this happening to him? Him getting
like mercilessly just bered like mocked out of this call. Okay.
I used to feel empathy for Connor because of this call. Can you
believe that? I can feel empathy for anybody. That's kind of
embarrassing to admit to tell you the truth. I used to feel bad
for this guy. He wasn't a detective. No, he was not. No, he was
not. Okay, we're doxing Jtock now and not spicy. Oh, Jeffrey
Tinkle. So far,
By all means, we can mention that guys have gotten weaker and
whinier, whatever you want to say. >> Keep in mind, this
is all coming from people who say Destiny is an e or by
Uh, wait. Those are valid arguments. Why would you? What? What
is the counterargument to rap by deception?
If you wanted to do the deception, like if you did believe rap
deception is a thing, what's the counter-argument there? There
isn't a counterargument >> But the reality >> so
lift weights
is I won't make any excuses for it. I didn't have a family in
my 20s. I just I just I just had a kid for the first time. >> Where
where was my >> I just wanna I I feel like I always I have
to keep pointing this out. Okay. If I just wanted to isolate
Destiny, why have I never once mentioned W or messaged Wes and
said, "Hey, Wes, you even got out of my way to say, "Hey, Wes,
you haven't been on in a while. Wes, you want to come on? Hey,
Wes, I miss you, buddy. You want to come on?" I never once pressured
that guy to leave Destiny because he's never said anything that
would lead me to believe that he had principles that he'd have
to violate to stay near Destiny ever. Did I say I didn't say
wessaged mess, did I? What? I generation men and women to be
like it is a social imperative to have a family now sorted out
>> for all the young guys >> I think he's >> they're
struggling to hire people
>> this is just the beginning Tims now million people talking
to Tim okay hold on we got one more time stamp one more at least
at least one more or is this it >> uh nightwell gang says
so the new evidence Kiwi Farms has found is ticket for Rose saying
she was 17 when Destiny started messaging her Good. This is all
things so bloody weird. Okay. Does that is it Rose saying
he knew I was 17. Here's Is that what happened? >> I agree.
Right. >> So, we live in a society that needs to be saying,
"What do you mean you don't have kids? That's crazy." Instead,
we live in a society where it's like, "Don't have kids. It's
bad for the >> Sure. And we kind of hate kids, right? Like,
there's a lot of families that move. It's just the the argument
would be like, I mean, >> wait, you want America to be
more than one race? Yeah, dude. We're already 24% Hispanic. We're
already 13% black. We're already like less than 5% Asian. We're
already 65% white. And white is already
>> Hold on a second. One second. Uh, Nightwell Gang says,
"So, the new This is all things so bloody weird." 17 here.
>> I might have missed something here. Hold >> I
can't say Destiny is a, but he's absolutely a predator. He hooks
up with crazy and insecure girls constantly while using his clut
as bait. Does he enjoy the power dynamic or is he lazy? Who knows?
>> I agree. Right. We live in a society that needs >> Why
did you cover the Destiny DMs when they look sus as since they
are on the right side of the screen? I literally said that I
have no reason to believe these are real right now, but if they
are, here's my thoughts. That was why I said there's no reason
to believe that these are real. Uh I don't like I'm just covering
these as if they're my thoughts.
Um but there is also that uh like there is also what is his name?
Solo has said that this was the case as well, right? So, like
there was already reason to believe that that conversation essentially
happened. Yeah. If you caught me doing it non-conditionally,
I'd just say, "Oh, that was a mistake." Uh, it should have been
conditional and like, "Hey, I don't think this is real." But
if it's real, if it's real >> to be saying, "What do you
mean you don't have kids?" That's crazy. Instead, we live in
a society where it's like, "Don't have kids. It's bad for the
>> Sure. And we kind of hate kids, right? Like, there's
a lot of families that move. It's just the the argument would
be like, I mean,
>> uh, apparently you need to deactivate the accounts role
or someone was saying it looks like that when you deactivate
accounts. I kind of am skeptical of it, but yeah. Okay, let's
baste. Yeah. Um, unfortunately or sorry, fortunately for us,
those DMs are not the cream of the crop that tonight, you know,
the creme de la creme. Those DMs were a nice cherry on top, but
they're not the creme de la creme, you know. Wait, you want America
to be more than one race? Yeah, dude. We're already 24% Hispanic.
We're already 13% black. We're already like less than 5% Asian.
We're already 65% white. I think this is the last metal jacket
all the time inside every Vietn >> because at some point
he decides he's going to pull up this >> drawing. Uh, no.
I meant you want them to be more of one race. Well, I mean I
like Hispanics. I think Hispanics are >> Also, I would
prefer like like listen, I'm going to be a little bit racist.
>> I would prefer
Hispanic immigration and Hispanic integration over mass Middle
Eastern and North African immigration and integration.
SCD's DM to Rose that came out with the leaks is pretty good.
Do we miss that? Is that on one of the Gatfumodor things? Link
link link link. >> I still think Middle Eastern and North
African immigration and integration is possible. I think it's
just more difficult than Hispanic. Hispanics are are Catholic.
They're Christian. They're a combination of Native Americans
and Spanish. They're technically already European in a lot of
ways. They have all the same problems that we have with like
African slavery and all that kind of.
>> so for me, like, yeah, I I think Hispanic immigration
is probably preferable and easier to integrate.
>> So yeah, Eric Dom says, "The Romans were pretty good
at reproducing their civilization in their conquered provinces,
as far as I know. So were the Chinese." True. Yeah. But inside
like uh for instance, there's this quote from Full Metal Jacket
I quote all the time.
Is an American Full Metal Jacket I quote all the time. Inside
every Vietnamese, >> I for a second thought he said Full
Metal Alchemist and I was like, "Wait, what?" That's why I paused
there. I thought he was saying Full Metal Alchemist for a second,
but he said Full Metal Jacket. >> This person is an American
waiting to come out. Now, he didn't say a Vietnamese person.
He said the the G slur, the G O K slur. Uh, but I actually stand
by that sentiment
>> inside. A lot of people are Americans. So, anyways,
let me go ahead and draw this. There was somebody who >> especially
when American GIS invade any foreign country then inside many
of those people a lot of the women okay there's an American >> kind
of asked it and they were being a little bit of a smartass but
they weren't being like too bad
um I think it was Jeffrey Hinkle doxing Jtock now and not spicy
right so let me show you the accusation okay so why show me the
accusation and not the proof I it's so worthless
to show the accusation and no proof It's so useless. Right here,
let me show you the baseless accusation. No, how about you tell
this guy to stop being a weirdo and making baseless accusations?
How about you tell the guy who's your friend that it looks really
insane? Looks like he is losing his mind when he just makes baseless
Spicy chat
is largely
uh Chud's Discord, right? It's a channel in Chud's Discord. By
the way, I support Chud's mission of having a place
that is uh Chud Logic
that is uh terms of service only. So you can discuss whatever
you want to discuss what as long as it's within terms of service.
That's my understanding of uh Spicy, right? And somebody from
Spicy can correct me if I'm wrong.
Connor about the anti-fan. One thing you need to pay attention
to is that would want to moral frog you. They have this moral
supremac uh supremacist when the people they had support follow
are not that different. Uh sure but we should still contend arguments
on their face even if the arguments are bad faith. I don't and
I'm not saying bad faith too moral frog. I'm saying bad faith
as in they're not doing they're not doing it because they actually
care that Steven was goo a gooner several years ago. They're
doing it because they're trying to get all the people around
Steven to call Steven a piece of and to distance
>> themselves. This is just this is I have an easy counter
example for this. Like the easiest counter example. It's just
>> from him. That's obviously the objective or it seems
like the objective. >> I hope Connor understands this,
right?
Hold on. Cuz like I hope if Connor were watching for some reason,
okay, I just hope he understands that I'm not calling you out.
I'm not telling you to call Destiny out because you're friends
with Destiny. I'm telling you to do it because you've stated
principles against the things that he's doing and against the
things he's done. And you are not upholding those principles
in any way. That's the criticism. And I have people who don't
have those principles. I didn't I actually kept talking or I
would have kept talking to Dan. I still kept talking to Dan.
I didn't tell Dan to go disavow Destiny, right? Cuz I don't think
Dan has principles. Same with Wes. Wes doesn't have any principles
on this. Oh, hold on. keep >> So unless there's new information,
uh I'm not I'm not ch I'm not changing my perspective unless
there's new information. Right. >> There is new information,
but he as the new information has come in, he's changed what
he's going to say. So >> um so spicy chat,
uh Discord terms of service service are the only rules.
Okay, that that's spicy chat as far as I understand it. Right.
Um I want to be able to see spicy chat, right? There we go. Okay.
Are the only rules then?
>> Dan wasn't blackmail blackmailing me. Well, Dan did
after we had the anything else bet. He did say that if I didn't
back off, he was going to dox me. He he threatened the same thing
on Darius's stream. So, that was a threat with the docs. But,
I mean, that was just saying like, "Hey, I will dox you." Except
he says it in like a different way that he thinks it means it's
not threatening to doc. He's like, "Well, you you're anonymous
and I'll drag you out into the light." Or something along those
lines, right? It's like very obvious what he means and what he's
doing and we know, we know, we know. So, um, so he did all that
and then later the blackmail, quote unquote, is like I told people
that I had, um, like docs related information in my DG logs and
he started posting old logs to me that I had deleted because
they had doxing information and that was what I said was like,
are you trying to menace me with like my docs information or
so those are the things that happened. He was never like, "Oh,
if you don't like shut up about this." Well, I think he did say
he did kind of blackmail me with the anything else stuff. But
I was kind of blackmailing him, so you know, turnabout is fair
play in that situation, maybe.
Less less heat for that one. We have uh Quean, who let's admit
it, um Chud does want to um have Quean be his own entity, and
that's true. I I think Queman, what what did he get? He gets
between like 300 and 700 viewers, depending on what he's talking
about. I think Queeman,
if I'm proud of 100 to 200 live viewers, depending on topic,
I think Queman should be proud of 300 to 700. So, I would say
Quean started as a a Chudlo Chudlogic Orbiter.
Uh, but he's effectively his own drama YouTuber now, in my opinion.
Then we have And then we got like K chord, right? So,
K chord.
>> I use I use paint for this.
I use paint for this. >> Uh, here we go. Similar to spicy
chat. Similar to spicy chat. Uh, in that you can pretty much
endlessly rewrite it. Uh, endlessly talk about anybody. I don't
know what the terms of service are, but that's that's the kind
of culture in my opinion is that you can endlessly talk about
anybody in Queen and that's not a term of service violation.
Being like manically focused on a single person is not a terms
of service violation and it's also not like a community violation.
They're not going to get you out of that. And then JSTock, in
my opinion, is like the number one Destiny Alo, right? JTO, and
I'm going to put Riyle. I know that they're supposedly not affiliated,
but JTO got banned off of YouTube very early on. And so Riyle,
in my opinion, they don't have to agree with me, but Riyle is
effectively like uh he is Destiny's like number one YouTube alog.
He takes all of the J-Tock hate streams and he publishes them
to YouTube. >> Yeah, but also Connor's Connor unfortunately
says this. Ry posts that stuff because he gets views. That's
like not the the broad majority of the content. It's really not.
I do like deep dives. I do like a log people's streams and stuff,
but like I went after pirate software for a bunch. I've gone
after Hassan a bunch. It's like a lot of different people we
go after, okay? There's a lot of different people we follow and
cover fairly, but they are people who have a lot of flaws, okay?
And Destiny is just one of them. So, while I do while I do feel
obsessed and like uh I hate Destiny, okay, I just I hate the
idea that I'm like his number one ALOG. Really, taking that away
from Queenman just feels really wrong to me, okay? feels really
weird, really mean. >> So, uh, number one, number one,
uh, Destiny Alo, right? And so, what happened was that I think
that everybody will agree that there is a substantive amount
of crosspollination
between these three uh, chats. And the reason why is because
Chlo just likes to cover whatever, right? Like he's an equal
opportunity drama frog. Although, weirdly enough, he has distanced
himself from uh, Twitch and YouTube politics. And so, as a result,
I actually think he has less Destiny Alogs than Queen or Destiny.
But, I think they still have like a similar like vibe, right?
And so the accusation is that in spicy chat I forget who this
guy's name is. Court noi court rose court something right is
that there was a guy name in court something who was famous on
Kiwi Farms he was in spicy chat he docked somebody he was banned.
Then after he was banned he came in on PFP and he was allowed
to be in this discord for prolonged period and I have no idea
how long he was in there. Again I don't know the details but
effectively the accusation is that all three of these communities
like uh they they enjoy kiwi farms. Right now that's not a crime.
It's not it's not a crime to enjoy kiwi farms. I think a little
bit of a schizophrenic but it's not a crime. Right? And to hear
the way that I've heard Chud Logic and Queen talk about kiwi
farms. They effectively say that's a drama archive. That's what
they they think it is. It's internet schizophrenics talk. >> No,
it's not just a drama archive. They don't think that. They're
aware of the other bad things that happen. They're aware that
people docks. Right. Right. They're aware of that. They're saying
that if you use it as a drama archive, if you use it as an archive
of information, a just a a potential tool in the tool belt that
you could go to to get information from, then that's not bad.
That's what everybody says. Talking about uh various uh various
characters, but it's a drama.
X Toprey. I know that cuz I remember talking to people about
the Lauren Southern stuff when KF was the only place posting
that. Okay. I remember DMing DJs about the KF stuff. I remember
>> archive that hosts doces
and uh by the way because they have pixies there for a while.
And so the whole point is that like technically none of this
is illegal, right? Talking [__] about people uh getting
public information, all that kind of stuff. None of that's illegal.
But the argument change it to red. The argument is that Sorry,
let me uh it's fine. I want to do a new one now. Thank you. Okay.
So the argument is that there is an uncomfortable level of familiarity
between spicy chat and jtox community that goes to kiwi farms
and basically gets that information popularizes it within the
YouTube political community and then does the things that we
saw today where effectively we had half a dozen dozen people
who came in like oh right
the evidence is on the evidence is on kiwi farms the evidence
on ki farms evidence is on hold on but that dude that's just
where the information came out wait what if I'm sorry that that
you don't like it but that's like how a lot of stuff works dude
how do you think um like OS in stuff works Right? Would this
not just be the same pattern as like OS in stuff? There'd be
some message board where there's like really unhinged and it's
like low quality information and then somebody else with like
a higher level of like a higher level of um discernment comes
wrong comes wrong and and discerns and tells us what is uh going
on. You know, somebody with a different level of discernment
comes along and validates and figures out what's going on there
and then presents it in a different forum. I learned it from
Twitter, so we should end Twitter next. Yes. Also, like if KF
didn't exist, this stuff could just be posted on Twitter. I'm
not sure that anything that gets posted on KF would be toos on
Twitter. Like I'm I'm actually not sure or if it is, it's not
to enough that like I don't know. There's just no way to prevent
the proliferation. It's all information on the internet unfortunately.
And so what Stephen is saying is, okay, you're my number one
agog. You're the largest Twitch and YouTube person who um who
has Destiny Alogs in your community. You're the second largest
Destiny Alog/drama person. All of your communities are going
to kiwi farms and you're taking a look at, you know, revenge
in boxes and all that kind of stuff. And then when Steven and
his orbit get doxed, you act like, well, I logic can probably
truthfully say, well, I have nothing to do with that and I don't
encourage that bad behavior. Queen can probably truly say, I
have nothing to do with that and I don't engage in that behavior.
Jen House can say, well, I have nothing to do that do with that
and I don't encourage that behavior. But effectively, what happens
is a substantive amount of the content that JC produces is Destiny
is the most evil piece of >> this is like actually just
totally
Like I should I all I have to do is compare the amount of time
I stream to the amount of content on Riyle's channel that is
like Destiny. I'm getting I'm getting blamed for like Riyle's
selection of what content to upload. [__] you, Riyle.
You for creating this >> on the [__] planet
and deserve to die and burn in hell. Uh Queenman also seems to
have I'm going to put it tactfully a quite negative opinion of
Steven and then Queen calls Steven for complaining about getting
doxed and harassed. And so I mean if if I had to summarize what's
going on right now, this is why Chloic hasn't been doxed but
Steven has I believe launched a counterdocation against Routin
House and JCO and his orders. And I think they also launched
a counterdox operation against women. I don't know. I don't involve
myself in these gay operations. But the reason why is because
they are effectively uh facilitating the Kiwi Farms community
to be co-hosted in No, there's no
There's just no co-hosting
at all. Is that even the majority of R's content? I don't know.
It was for a little bit. It was for a little bit. Like I know
whenever I do Destiny stuff, like other stuff go up, but it's
is what it is. That's like Ral's got to eat. Okay. Ral's got
to eat. I guess the issue might be that Kiwi Farms is archive.
Is he forgetting that his community also has this information
stored in their brains?
For for me or for Destiny, like Destiny, like all of Destiny's
fans also go on KF. Destiny coordinates with people who post
on KF. Like I don't know.
Unfortunately, it's just there, right? It's just there. And not
just being like, "Oh, well, I'm going to ignore information there."
Like, what? How long do I have to ignore for sick? Post that
[__] on Twitter right away. Once it's on Twitter,
is it good or is Twitter like supporting? Are you allowed to
dox Elon Musk now? I think his name's Elon Musk. Whatever. Yes,
Destiny supported KF. Destiny does not at it like a base level
hate KF. It's obviously true. Crossedated into the Twitch and
YouTube political scene. That's the accusation. I'm not saying
it's correct. I don't know the evidence. I don't participate
in I know that Coro Roy Corvoy. I know that thing was documented
that there was a child. I'm sorry. I genuinely apologize. I'm
not trying to make a negative association. Um there was a Kiwi
farmer in Spicy Chat who was banned and then came back under
an old. I know that that incident was uh documented, but but
I don't know anything else with that. Um, what did Destiny do
with Keles again? Uh, wrote a manifesto and pointed and admitted
that there was a hyperdocumented Keles Kiwi Farms thread, right?
That's fair. >> Is wait, is that fair? A hyperdocumented
Keles thread like the one on Destiny.
>> do you But but I don't know anything else with that.
Um, what did Destiny do with Keles again? Uh, wrote a manifesto
and pointed and admitted that there was a hyperdocumented Kles
Kiwi Farms thread. Right. That's fair. That feels like an accurate
description of reality. I mean, I'm happy to take uh any criticisms
on my graph. Uh, no. No says if you aren't changing your own
destiny, why you why are you entertaining me? These stuck because
I try to follow the truth wherever it leads me, right? Jeff says, "I
don't care if the game do seems weird to me." Okay, I mean, I
agree with you there, but okay. Wasn't trying to be bad faith.
Okay, listen. I I don't do gays. I don't I don't want to do gays.
>> I dude I also don't know. They've built me up as like
a they built me up as some kind of insane boogeyman. It's really
not like that at all. I remember on our Destiny people getting
downvoted like crazy for being comfortable with Destiny's support
of KF.
>> I don't want to be involved in boxing. Um, however,
I think Steve's position is that he's been doxed, harassed, and
swatted repeatedly. It's not stopping. And his number one Alogs
are still milking the [__] out of the content while
knowingly uh cultivating communities that would be interested
in doxing, stalking, harassing, and socially isolating. >> Knowing
and cultivating communities. Where is the proof that we've even
cultivated this community? All the people who type regularly
in my chat are former Destiny fans. How the did I cultivate this
community when I when I like literally just broke off a chunk
of his when I when he showed himself for who he was? I don't
even understand how you can make this argument. All the people
who support me former Destiny fans
essentially all of them. What's the Ralph post? What's Ralph
posting?
This guy is stupid as [__]
Yeah. Like dude, everything this guy posts just shows that he's
like lost it completely.
Like I get it. Listen, you know what? You know why I entertained
that Really conversation said it was a good exercise? Just in
my mind, Destiny has lost it so badly that I'm sitting here like,
dude, there's there's no way like it makes me feel like unsure
of my own sanity that I used to find this guy compelling. I used
to think he was intelligent and now he has lost it so badly that
he is he thinks this is like a compelling post of some kind.
He thinks this was a thing. He think he thinks he like might
have cooked here. He thinks this isn't embarrassing,
right? And I'm like, dude, he's like he has to be pretending
to be. He has to be or else how the did I think this guy had
anything valid to say.
How stress limits your brain power or something? I'm like, dude,
I really I almost like in the back of my head I'm like I almost
hope it's 40 chess cuz otherwise I I I thought this guy was compelling.
He's a total loser. He's actually a total loser. Like what? Huh?
Anyway, continue. Um yeah, Christian says J Queenack is exceptional,
but the community engage with TV farms to continue to do. Well,
another accusation that I heard, again, I don't know the raffy
of it, but another accusation I heard is that effectively, a
bug squander and stylo are normally on kiwi farms. You know,
it's just it's just a thing. It's part of the culture. >> Bug
squander and what >> I heard is that effectively a bug
squander in Styo are normally on kiwi >> So, you can just
dox anybody who's been on kiwi farms. Not that he's proven that
at all, by the way. Not that he's proven that. And he throws
out names of these people, right? He's going to say, "Oh, well,
apparently these people are on kiwi farms." Cool. Cool, dude.
>> Um they they you know, it's just it's just a thing.
It's part of the culture. It's not illegal, right? It's not >> Jeffrey
Hinkle. I'm sorry I watched Dest for too long. To accept trust
me, bro is an argument. Exactly. Thank you, Jeffrey >> I legal
to be on Kiwi farms. It's not >> It's not illegal, but
you're justifying doxing against them or >> illegal
uh to a log people. It's not illegal to look at their docs andor
look at leaked. Uh, however, um, you know, the question is whether
or not you're cultivating a community that's so toxic that you
end up doxing and harassing people or getting people swatted.
So >> that you end up doxing and harassing people are getting
he was horrible at the end of our situation. Ironically, Jtock
had duplicated the same behavior with Cherry. Nope.
Totally made up, totally fabricated. I don't understand how pe
like people think this at all. The issue with Okay. The issue
with the Anapor thing was he was calling her a stalker, destroying
her reputation publicly while her privately and telling her he
would fix it if she kept kept engaging in a relationship. That
is not something that's ever happened with me and Cherry. That's
never ever ever happened. That's crazy. Okay. These people just
these people just make things up. This is creative. Crazy. Uh
Jtock Discord is talking about the stream right now. Sure. Sure.
I'm sure. Jeffrey says, "I wasn't talking about Destiny though,
dude. I was explaining what I thought was weird to me that everybody
just says it's happening but doesn't link anything. >> Yeah,
I agree. Uh I agree. I before I would want to
engage in any kind of some reason people care more about doxing
and not the swatting which is exceptionally worse given it's
a crime that results in people getting killed by police.
Um I am once again Uhhuh. You can't tr you can't trust this person.
Okay.
[__] Shut up. I don't know. Um, hold on. What was
I going to say? Oh, uh, again, I'm going to lay this out. I believe
that Aerodite I need I need examples or proof that Aerodite moved,
got redoxed, and got re-watted. Okay. Cuz what she told me and
what she said on anything else in at New Year's when I was still
firmly on Destiny's, you know, plantation, okay,
was she said that she'd already been swatted multiple times?
Multiple swatting attempts. You tell me after multiple swatting
attempts, the cops didn't write your address down. Is that what
you're telling me? Cuz then she tried to come in and say, "Oh,
well, uh, I got swatted because of these people." No. Off. You're
just blaming Kiwi Farms on me. You're blaming you're blaming
like your docs being somewhere on me with no evidence that have
anything to do with it is entirely what Destiny and other people
excoriated Keles for. Okay, do not try to get somebody cancelled.
Do not try to with a whole website, a whole community because
a different community who you find scarier is attacking you.
You don't put me in the middle. Don't make me a target. Stupid
[__] Like doxing counter gay ops. Number one, I don't
want to do that at all. Uh, but if I was going to go after Riyle
or go after Jtock or go after Chud or go after Queman, I would
want some kind of evidence that they were personally involved,
not that they
um cultivated toxic communities, right? Because if we went after
everybody who cultivated a quote unquote toxic community, then
there would be no online communities,
right? Uh, number four, I think was alluding to hypocrisy, effectively
saying that like Steven did a giant manifesto on Keffles and
mentioned the fact that Kiwi Farms had a information, right?
Mick says this is a genetic fallacy. Who cares where the info
comes from if it's accurate? Uh, I I don't think I've made any
I don't think I've made any dismissals of the information. I
don't think I've said that. I I don't Mick, I think you're you
prepared an argument that doesn't contradict anything I've said.
St. And Patty says, "Watting is [__] evil. Doxing
is for stragg. God, I hate snarkers. Worse kind of people." Sure.
Uh Jeffrey Hingle says, "Genuinely, I don't understand the logic
that these guys are really mean and talk about me too much. I
can dox you." Well, sure. But he thinks the the issue to me is
that my community had like backed off. We'd like stopped covering
Destiny quite a bit. Like we we really backed almost all the
way off of covering this guy, right? It was only I was covering
like court updates like by myself just reading court documents,
right? and Destiny started engaging with my community and a bunch
of around me for no reason. You covered Hutch's injuries, his
story seems a bit fishy. Nope, haven't covered it at all. Sat
there playing cutesy
uh with and and footsy with these communities.
So, you know, again, uh if I was going to go after somebody that
hard, I would want hard evidence. Mick, you keep saying the genetic
fallacy you don't even understand. I'm not even dismissing that
the information on Kiwi Farms is a problem. You [__]
idiot. You
just saying kiwi farms is a problem. You [__] idiot.
Ow. Ow. Ow. Ow. My tongue. Ow. The is that and disavow ks etc.
But it isn't until recently that they've actually banned people.
Desi has made them hold to disavow which is hilarious.
Wait,
have I banned like additional people? I could have sworn. I don't
think I've banned like any additional people. Like Corfire was
banned before he joined or like as he joined like years ago or
sorry like a year ago but other than that I don't think we're
banning people for like honestly the bigger deal was this morning
people trying to get or last night people trying to come in from
DG like DG is coming in going oh you guys are saying that like
Rose was a minor. Um can you show me proof? Can you like link
me proof right now? I'm like guys do not try to link them proof.
They're trying to get you to link like KF or something so you
can get a run to Destiny and he can go, "Oh, look. It's proof.
It's proof. It's proof." Yeah. Straight to the E defense squad
channel for you. Okay. Straight there.
>> You just saying genetic fallacy over and over again
doesn't do anything. You
>> uh nothing nothing that bad happened. Full of hell.
It was just a couple DJs joined cuz you know, >> it is
what it is. Have I denied that any of the documented wrongdoing
is uh incorrect just because it emanated from Kiwi Farms? That
never happened. You just made up a problem.
It's funny, dude. You You guys You guys kind of suck, too. Anyone
in Connor's Discord, come see me. I have something to show you.
Christian Lair says, "At worst, he told his audience to go to
Kiwi Farms if they want to engage in drama around Anna and Keles."
Sure. Uh Big and Gaming says, "Alapone famously never illegally
sold booze because the government never arrested him for it."
Got it. No, no, no. So, so I'm not even I'm not even implying
like uh conspiracy. I'm I'm trying to be descriptive.
The And the thing about Mick uh that pissed me off, Mick genetic
What does the genetic fallacy have anything to do with anything
that I've said? Like, this is what pissed me off
>> these people, right? >> Hold on. I'm going to
let Connor cook. I have to go get some water. I'm uh I'm dying
of thirst right now. I'll be right back. Two seconds
if you want to engage in drama around Anna and Keles. Sure. Big
Gaming says Alapone famously never illegally sold booze because
the government never arrested him for it. Got it. No, no, no.
So, so I'm not even I'm not even implying like uh conspiracy.
I'm I'm trying to be descriptive.
The And the thing about Mick uh that pissed me off. Mick genetic
What does the genetic fallacy have anything to do with anything
that I've said? Like this is what me off about
these people, right? The the the dozen people who come in and
they're like, "Hey, Steven's a Steven's."
Is like you won't even listen to the counterarguments being profered.
You're just saying genetic fallacy. But a genetic fallacy doesn't
change anything about what I said. The genetic fallacy means
that because information comes from a bad source, you dismiss
the
I don't think I've dismissed any information.
And if anything, I've asked for additional information. And um
when it comes to this association,
I can
why Chudlo Logic uh let me find the
I could understand why Chudlo Logic is
about this association.
Uh, give me a second because he, in my opinion, has gone out
of his way not to cover Twitch and YouTube politics. So, so like
there there's actually times I wish Chud Logic would cover Twitch
and YouTube politics more because frankly I like his coverage.
Um, but Chud seems to be allergic to Twitch and YouTube politics.
I don't know why. Um, but I could understand how he would be
the >> I'm back. Connor said he didn't do the genetic fallacy.
I could have sworn at some point he got like somebody said, "Oh,
the info is on KF." And he went, "Oh, well, that's problem one."
Wasn't that like the thing he replied with? Oh, that's problem
one. Oh, Technommancer, I misclicked on you, buddy, earlier.
I'm sorry. I literally just saw on another page you were banned.
Uh, I'm sorry. I totally misclicked on you.
Uh, that's my bad, dude. I I don't know how that happened. I
know you're a big fan. So,
>> because he's gone out of his way to avoid this or at
least avoid it in so far as affecting DGG. I think that's part
of the reason why
um Chud hasn't been doxed is because he's gone out of his way.
>> What's up, Caz? Yeah, I saw you were uh Yeah, I saw
you talking to >> not to involve himself with Twitch and
YouTube politics. However, I don't think Jtock or Ry Kittenhouse
will deny that they're Destiny's number one a log. And then I
don't think Queman would deny that he endlessly talks. I just
Queman's got so much knowledge from before that I don't it just
feels weird. He was like a bigger part of that community for
a way longer time.
I feel like it's hard to say you're Destiny's number one Alog
when you've been around for like
>> right? I think that uh I've heard Quean defend
the concept that Kiwi Farms is ultimately just a drama archive.
So what's the problem? I think I've heard him articulate that.
Destron says, "Uh, the issue is that Queenman and Jtock disavow,
uh, Kiwi Farm, Snarks, etc., but it isn't until recently that
they had actually banned people. Destiny has made them hold to
disavow, which is
Um, yeah, but I there should be evidence of that, right? >> I
think I've seen Queen not disavow. I think he said like he doesn't
engage in
Uh but you know he's not,
you know, uh he's he's not going to enforce that his community
doesn't engage with Kiwi Farms, right? That's not something that
he's going to >> What? That's something you can't
All you can do is prevent your community from posting Kiwi Farms
links in your you can't like say they can't they can't talk about
it. You can't even really stop them from referencing it. Like
that's just stupid, right? That's saying, "Oh, information from
that's literally doing the genetic fallacy thing." If you say
you can't even reference info that's on KF, right? Like that's
stupid. That's all that would be silly. At worse, he told his
audience to go to Kiwi Farms. I think I read that one. I dismissed
the evidence. It's weak.
Okay. Destro says Christian Destiny pretty much said, "Don't
do the bull in my community. Go to Kiwi Farms, which is val,
but also sending people to Kiwi Farms is bad." Sure. My point
is just saying there is no proof, but somehow everyone who has
never ever totally disavowed Destiny has been doxed. Yeah, dude.
And I'm not going to be surprised if uh I'm probably going to
call my local police department now and say, "Hey, if you get
a call at my address, I've recently talked to
um or talked about some internet schizophrenic."
Will you ban these juice douchebags if they keep up with this
rhetoric for more than a day? I'm about to tap out on watching
this.
Okay. Cass appears to be in this community,
but I dude I don't I don't send these people around. I don't
know this. Okay. I don't know avow this.
So, if you get a call at this address, you know, don't come in
guns blazing. You know, I'm probably just going to do that as
a precautionary measure
because what? Technone got docs last week.
>> Within the last week and he talked to Steven two weeks
ago. Wait, did Teeone Wait, what was that in like the thread
or something? Techone. Uh, every stop doc scene each other. Okay.
Won't even touch the food shop stuff. Laugh my ass off. Jeffrey
Hinkle, you're No offense, bro, but like you're kind of stupid,
right? Like I I
>> Oh, I would love to talk to Connor. Son do talks his
dad's crimes. That's true. >> Talk about everything. You
guys are just not used to me. You guys are just not used to me.
Um, do you admit that Destiny is doing more to normalize by promoting
food shops
than Chud or Queenman ever did, even though you criticized them
like and like massively for it? >> So, we'll talk about
food shops. So, food shops. >> Okay, cool. >> Food
shops. I already went over the food shops drama earlier. So,
uh, food shops. Uh, I think she really just has a stream. I don't
know how big her community is. Um, but I'll I'll go ahead and
say how soon do I need to leave? It's 2:51. Okay, I I'm late,
so I got to go soon. But anyways, >> okay, Conor's about
to explain to us why he's about to explain to us why it's totally
fine for Destiny to do this, to promote food shops. Let's go.
>> I don't know why it's so small. >> Let's go. >> My
apologies.
uh runs a anti-JStock
skitso stream. And I hope she doesn't uh I'll spell it like Tom.
I'll honor Tom. Skitso stream. Um I hope she doesn't feel offended
by that characterization, but I I feel like that's relatively
accurate.
And so what Food Chops has done and Food Chops,
you know, I I hope she does well as a drama streamer. Um, but
what she's done
is she has said like, "Oh yeah, I consume Lollcon. I don't give
a all y'all." Yeah, I know. Um, my wife does not approve of the
discourse we're engaged in right now. Um, but food shops has
started to try to milk uh Quean
and uh Jtock. Actually, hold on. Let me fix the drawing. Uh,
food shops has started trying to milk Jtock and Queman,
but truth be told, this might be justified from her perspective
and effectively uh the reason why it might be justified from
food shop's perspective. So, okay, lollycon gross. Okay, hate
hate lollycon. Disgusting, repulsive. Stop doing it. We already
did content about that earlier. But from food shops perspective,
I think she's genuinely a DGG fan. So she's beefing with J-stock
because JTO is, you know, their number one ALOG. And then food
shops is beefing with Queenman limited, but still beefing with
Queenman because Queen Well, hold on. I mean, it's technically
milking cuz she's getting like raids from Destiny to like getting
incentivized to do it. So she is going to be making money eventually,
right? I don't know how much at all. It's so funny how Hardy
went on food shops and Chud's stream. I mean, I looked at I think
we covered something to do with that recently, didn't we? Can
I go Can I go over to I I don't know. I had the the clip up the
other day. I watched it. >> Uh used to a log the out of
food shops.
So her position herself as being willing to go into the schizophrenic
Kiwi Farms adjacent drama commentary community actually has
he said he will raid her daily from now on.
That's fine. I mean unfortunately it's going to become pretty
obvious to a lot of these people exactly like what she is exactly.
Yeah. Exactly what she is exactly.
Uh it'll become obvious to people. I'm sorry. You can't make
somebody who's that who who like can't speak who never gives
insightful commentary. You just can't make them popular. I don't
believe that's possible.
Dude, I'm not joking when I tell you Darius could provide more
insightful commentary on all of this stuff and has than she does.
He's a thousand% more capable and that's staggering.
carved her out. A >> also just as an aside from a racist
point of view, how did how did food shops roll multiple
critical fails on a d20 in terms of intellect or her like genetics?
That's like so up. I don't know what Asian people look like when
they have Down syndrome, but I'd imagine it's something like
that. Decent
uh she's like a 100red viewer streamer, bro. Um, she's carved
out like a decent skitso
anti-JTOK, anti-queenman
audience. So,
yeah. Anyways, Jeffrey Hle, are you talking about the Anavoir
stuff? Connor is fair. I am fair. I am fair. Jeffrey Henle says,
"I've watched you since Twitter gate. I said I'm not going to
touch it, not you." Oh, you're not going to touch food shops.
Gotcha.
Okay. All right. My My apologies for misunderstanding. Christian
Blair says, "Lollycon not good, but food shops has the same opinion
as Queenman." So, I mean, right.
>> Play the clip. Are you talking about your streamable
from earlier? Your skitso streamable. Full health. >> For
the goose is good for the gander. >> What the [__]
was that?
Should have >> pedos are not as bad as it's not even close.
Okay, cool. >> Not that one >> metaphorically in
a book, but I've thought that since she said she wanted to rap
sent me this earlier. I don't know what this is. It scares me.
Scares me a little bit. What is this? Not this. How bad does
this get? How bad does this get? Is this nothing? >> When
I was young, I got
>> Dude, full of hell, what is wrong with you? What is
this in 2004? Full of hell, what is What is wrong with you? Full
of hell. What is your major malfunction? What? What is your major?
Why? Why? I disavow. I disavow. That's not funny.
That's not funny. Okay, that's not funny. Oh, that's crazy. That's
crazy, dude. That's crazy. herself around a 13-year-old. Yeah,
that's gross. Don't do that. >> Oh, wait. There's no way.
But I've thought that since she said she wanted to wrap herself
around a 13-year-old. >> Wanted to wrap herself around
a 13-year-old. Yeah, that's gross. Don't do that. >> It's
gross. What do you want me to say? It's gross. What do you want
me to say? >> Don't do that. It's gross. We Dude, we had
an entire If you want to rewind the VOD, the VOD's now like 5
hours and change. Uh, in the VOD, >> somehow Conor is like,
"Guys, I disapp once today. What do you want me to be mad that
this is associated with me now? What do you want me to be like
annoyed or say that I don't I'm going to disavow or distance
from this person just cuz they're a I already I already disavowed
4 hours ago. You guys want me to do it again? Are you serious?
We tal we watched who is it? Come on, man. Anyways, the the normie
guy the normie guy who does all the news. I forget his name.
Philip DeFranco. We watched Philip DeFranco cover the Hassan
drama. We started watching Destiny call out Hassan for sweeping
for additional terrorism. But effectively that entire segment
has nothing to do with terrorism because what I would do is I
would let Destiny talk about how Hassan is a terrorist sweeping
piece of and how he can eat a barrel of dick. But every 3 minutes
I stopped and I fought the three to five lolliccons that were
in my community that were trying to defend the movie
So
that you know so so effectively we we had like an early lollycon
war earlier today.
So lollycon's bad. >> Don't consume lollycon. It's bad
for your soul. Um I'll just save this as the I don't know drama
commentary KF map. But I I feel like my map is like a fair articulation
of what people perceive.
I I don't feel like it's unfair at all. I just don't know how
any of the stuff I don't know how any of the stuff he has in
that map justifies any of Destiny's actions. That's the problem.
You can say that's the perception. The issue isn't your description
at all. I like I don't care what your description is. The issue
is does your prescription actually make sense. What is What is
Destiny doing about it? What is your prescription for that? His
prescription for that is I'm going to dox all these people. Destiny
is memeing through this. Oh, is he still posting? Jesus, he's
posting a lot. Uh Jeffrey Engel says, "I literally learned about
her from Connor." Yeah. Uh, that's not Lolly Connor. Yeah, sure.
Saying that you want to wrap yourself around a 13-year-old is
absolutely. I hope she's moved away from that kind of stuff in
the past several years. Jeffrey Engel says, "Now Destiny raids
her watching Nathan." That's pretty brutal. Uh, can we at least
throw food shops under the bus? Yeah, go ahead. Go ahead. Gen
X's, that one is interesting. Not really dangerous on a collective
level for sure. Dangerous on a personal individual level. I wouldn't
really try to say which is worse without a example. Gotcha. Uh,
Gen X, wrong chat. She hasn't moved away. This has absolutely
been a roller coaster stream. >> Yeah, I I think Rey's
just got to admit that this guy isn't who he thought he was.
And possibly she would have been 17 and a half, you sick. You're
really back in here, bro.
I don't know what this is about. I'm sorry. It's just all
And we've had all the emotions today. Thank god Sam Adams came
out with Oktoberfest. I need a few. Absolutely. Today was kind
of rough. Uh, she still does the same stuff. Okay, then you know
I think that that's evil and stupid and she shouldn't do any
of that. Anonymous chatter says, "Oh, never mind. It spilled
into his chat. They were talking about that in Discord." Interesting.
Okay.
anyways, I'm going to thank the people who have donated today.
Uh, Fast and Bulbas, Numac, Starhawks,
Gen X. Okay. All right. All right. That's it for uh Connor. I'm
trying to think of what else I want to do on this stream. I think
I've gotten everything I needed to do. The other thing I had
to do
was I was just going to watch the um I don't know Billy Eyish
Millie B. >> There's some juicy moments from this. Aba
debates Destiny on Drake's allegations. You remember this stuff,
guys? Do you remember this? When Destiny's like, "No, what is
she going to What is that 13-year-old girl going to talk about
with her parents? Her stupid parents, someone her own age?
Talk about me.
Talk about me." One second here. Here, I'm going to hit play
on this. I think apparently there's some like thing. >> Is
that weird? >> I think we even chatted a little bit. Like,
is that bad that I talked to a what is she 15 16 year old girl?
Is that like inapprop like is my niece, right? Is sister's child
is niece family is different? No, it's it's not really that different.
It just depends on the space that you share with each other.
That's the thing that makes Hold on. Let me go. Uh, do we have
a time stamp for when Abba joins? Time stamp. Aba joins. Time
stamp. Aba joints time stamp. Aba joints. I'll just find it.
I'll just find it. [__] it. >> Friend she has
at high school. You know, she's telling every single is a mentor.
>> Uh when he
>> might have someone that could
>> Uh closely everyone's been following this. But >> okay,
we're going to do this and then I'm looking for other stuff.
We'll see. I think there's other stuff I do want to do. There's
lots of tweets and today as well. If you follow hip hop or if
you're following entertainment news, Drake has been in this ongoing
battle, this rap feud with Kendrick Lamar. So, tell us about
that a bit. Yeah, and that's really been heating up uh over the
last few days. It's a feud that's been going on for years, but
it really has ramped up in the last couple days with both musicians
releasing multiple tracks aimed at each other. Uh >> and
the two African-American music industry creators at each other
and the the beef is uh quite harsh. Uh Brad, thanks Emily. in
the last couple days with both musicians releasing multiple tracks
aimed at each other uh containing lyrics with pretty uh ugly
personal insults. Um one of the songs that Kendrick Lamar released
uh when he put it out on his social media channels the cover
art for that track included an image of this house behind me
of Drake's house and aerial um now it's pretty well known that
Drake has a mansion in Toronto in this area of put out by Kendrick
Lamar and again um both artists taking each other through their
lyrics very ugly feud that has had a lot of people talking in
recent days and then this the house earlier this morning there
is absolutely no evidence to suggest that feud is connected to
what happened here. Oh,
hello. >> Yes. Yes. You're you're a local. >> Here
we go. >> What's up? How you doing? >> See why you
thought I was a for assuming >> Oh, right. Didn't Destiny
say like if you think it's weird to talk to 13-year-olds about
you're probably a Wasn't that the take on this one? >> Or
making the leap that uh a grown man texting a teenager is uh
really weird. Actually, if you uh if you think it's weird for
a 13-year-old to talk to an adult, but um maybe you're a yourself
>> and inappropriate.
>> I I mean like I don't know what kind of space they've
shared or what kind of relationship they've had before that text
message to go on one line in a text message. There's like a million
conceivable ways that two celebrities could be interacting. It
just seems like a huge jump. It's like, oh, definitely must be
>> I think if you just look at it in a vacuum, then I would
agree with you. But it's not in a vacuum. If a self-admitted
is texting a teenager, yeah, you're probably going to have less
credibility than just >> Wait, wait. Is he a self-admitted
past? What does that mean? >> Yeah, the dude admits like
he's like completely obsessed with watching every day, bangs,
dating multiple women. >> Hold on. I'm Wait, wait. I'm
sorry. >> It's well documented. >> Wait, wait, wait.
Back up. Back up. Hold on. What does pest mean? >> This
is like, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Who
are we talking about again? Still Drake, right? It's still It's
still Drake, right? To you. Sorry. Let's make sure we're there.
>> Uh pest is basically somebody who uh lets govern their
lives in a lot of ways and then has a lot of bad habits in regards
to sex. Yeah. >> Okay. I don't think that that's the ordinary
definition of pest. What you just described sounds like a nyo
or like a addict, but pest carries a heavy implication of like
pressure or assault or something like that. >> Let me use
a different term. Sex addict or you know something. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Sure. >> Incredibly like >> promiscuous.
Okay. Okay. Yeah. Okay. Just check. Okay. Yeah. Because when
you say self admitted question makes it sound like he's admitted
to like assaulting or like pressuring girls >> Yeah. Okay.
Well, is there like any has there has there been any evidence
that it's come out of him like
doing or saying anything to like any of these girls? It's like
inappropriate or is it just that he's like texting them? >> No.
Uh it's that he's texting a bunch of them that he ends up sleeping
with some of them once they turn 18 after he's had relationships
with them in their teen years. Oh, I see I see names from this
chat in Destiny's chat, and that makes me uh >> Okay, wait,
what's like the strongest example of that? >> That would
be the Haley Bieber one. So, he knew her while she was a teenager.
She was 18 uh and he was like 29, 30. >> Wait, wait, wait.
So, we're already starting with her being an adult and then he
later on, you said he knew her when she started when she was
18. >> No, he knew her when she was 14. >> Oh, I
miss her. Sorry. Okay. All right. So Haley Bieber.
Oh Jesus. Okay. Control. What kind of relationship did they have
um when she was 14?
>> Friendship type of thing. >> Well, do we know
like what like what that meant or what's the context or what's
the like did they just like see each other at a party a few times
or were they like talking regularly or >> No, you would
invite her to birthday parties. They they they had >> When
you say invite her to birthday parties, are these like Drake
birthday parties where like a thousand people are showing up
or are these like small gettogethers with like five or 10 people?
Uh these are drink parties so there'll be a lot of people. >> Okay.
Is it And then is it confirmed that these two have actually like
even Is that like a 100% thing or >> I mean pretty much
aside from the fact that he's all over they had matching necklaces
of the H which is her last name. Uh or like she likes wearing
the initials of her partner whatever it is. And then yeah. So
sources close to them said they pretty much banged. >> Okay.
Um okay. What am I what am I supposed to care about here?
uh forming a relationship before the person is legally like a
a viable.
Oh, look. It's Zeus. It's Zeus
with his tier five sub. You see Zeus? It's him. >> Seems
like I feel like it's just a big >> Yes. It's uh it would
be grooming, right? Cuz I think they knew each other when she
was a minor. And then you form that relationship when they're
minor and then when they turn 18, you start dating them. That's
pretty weird, dude. >> What? No, no. What I'm you're trying
to say this is >> Darius is >> not necessarily abnormal
behavior. And I think for almost everybody else who would see
this kind of stuff, they would say this is absolutely creepy
behavior and this is someone who's most likely grooming people.
Uh >> well, hold on. Wait, wait. When I say not abnormal,
I've never said it's not abnormal behavior. A lot of this stuff
is can be abnormal. Wait, wait, wait. >> It's bad. What
do you want me to say? >> Let me just finish. His life
is abnormal, right? These are celebrities, so they're living
in a totally different world, right? I think that like the the
projection is so obvious, right? How many times have we heard
Destiny describe himself as you don't get it? I can't have friends
from the real world. They don't know what my world's like. I'm
a celebrity. They they have no idea what my world's like. I can't
possibly connect with them. I live a different life. I am a very
abnormal person. I'm a very I'm a very uh I'm an anomaly, okay?
My life is different. Don't live your life my way. Right? It's
literally everything about this applies to him. He thinks by
defending Drake, he's defending himself. I think you're extending
a huge amount of charitability to somebody who I think under
other circumstances as in with Daisy, I don't think you would
have done so. And with Daisy, you were right. Right. You looked
at her lifestyle and then you came to some decisions regards
to what kind of person she was and you didn't hedge that much
really. You said she was a horrible human being. Right. You made
some strong >> Wait, why did I say she was a horrible human
being? >> Why did Do you remember why I said she was a
horrible human being?
>> I said she was a horrible human being because when she
was on that call, she said that she was pregnant with Walter's
kid and even if he changed his tune, she was never going to let
him in the child's life. That's why I said she was a horrible
human being. I don't have to make any assumptions or do any digging
there. Um, I made some other assumptions about her lifestyle
based on everything I said. But God, that was good content. >> I
don't think any of the things that I made assumptions, all of
that was way more firm ground to stand on than anything related
to Drake, who's apparently texted some minors.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I think if you have a history of Texas
miners, following them on IG, uh, doing all that stuff, and yeah,
I think most people would not I don't even think it's a leap
for most people. That's a small hop to to sit there and be like,
"Wo, these people are making a giant claim." Like, is it really
that big of a claim? >> Yes. That you're minor that you'reing
minors. That's a really big claim. Yes. >> Hold up, hold
up, hold up. To be clear, the claim is grooming. >> Uh,
okay. Well, there's not even there's not a single shot of evidence
even of grooming minors.
>> Uh, no. I think having relationships with a bunch teenagers
and sleeping with them when they turn 18. I think that would
be like >> Wait, wait. So the I got one which was this
Haley Road Bieber person and I don't even know what their prior
quote unquote friendship was like and then we don't even 100%
know if they So this is the one example. Are there like tons
of these girls or is it like two whose stories are as solid as
this one? >> It would be two. So it' be two that is like
pretty much almost confirmed and then the rest of them is just
him constantly approach >> only. Everybody gets two. Come
on Abba. Everybody gets two groomings. pushing teenagers and
young girls and then texting them privately.
>> Can I ask? Do you think it's normal? >> Tom Fury
doing some wild sweeping. Oh, I might need a Tom link in a little
bit. Okay. If any time stamp, I'm going to get a drink really
quick. If there's any time stamps, you guys, let me I I'm down
for some time if we want to check it out. Dude, how up is it
that Tom rode he was ride or die with Destiny through the
drama
and then he has the same time slot as food shops and then Destiny
just starts raiding into food shops instead. How do you go on
as Tom? Tom literally he bet the entire farm on just sticking
by Destiny and then Destiny totally like was like, "Oh, nice.
Um, I'm going to go raid this actually." Hey Tom, you you're
like cool or whatever and I'm glad you're here but actually this
is who I want to kind of like uplift right now. So if you could
off
that's so dude
that's beyond.
Anyway, I'll see if we can check that out as well. We'll keep
listening to this. This is like just what I remember.
hits. It's not quite as it's not quite as good as I'd hoped.
Okay, it hits, but it's not quite there. Um if we got some tom
tent, some tom some sweeper tom tent. All right. I'd ask for
like the food chops time stamp to like find where she's doing
any kind of good argument, but we all know that that's not going
to happen, right? We all know that she's not Say what you will
about Tom. He is sentient. Okay, he does have like a a consciousness.
He can talk back to you. He can actually make arguments. All
>> for a grown man to be texting like 8 to 10 teenagers
and privately and then some of them he ends up sleeping with
>> in general. No. >> Okay. So even with Georgia
Smith, which has a different one, >> but if he's like if
he's at like casting parties and [__] or if they're
at celebrity parties, there's probably people of all ages here
and there's probably like these these people live in a totally
different world. >> They live in a different world. So
for them to be talking to underage people and sleeping with them
later is what? Normalized?
Do you think that's just like normal behavior in Hollywood?
>> Are you really asking me that? >> I'm asking >> Hold
on. What do we have? P. Diddy, R. Kelly. Are you asking me if
it's normal behavior in Hollywood? The normal stuff for celebrities
is way off the mark from whatever the normal >> You gave
me P. Diddy and R. Kelly, both people who are being indicted
for >> Yeah, but you're asking me like Wait, wait, wait,
wait. But you just said, "Is that normal in Hollywood?" implying
that like the standards of normal relationships in Hollywood
are going to be the same as the standards of normal relationships.
No, everything is going to be completely abnormal there. >> You
You gave me examples. I don't think it's actually normal. I do
think it happens and it may happen at a higher frequency. I don't
think it's normal. I don't think most Hollywood actors, if you
were to ask them or look through their phones, are texting a
bunch of teenagers. That's not normal. So, if I were to go through
like the Game of Thrones cast or the Harry Potter cast and you've
got like these little kids that work with you don't think any
of them don't I don't know if I'm making this up or if the weed
is summoning this from my brain somewhere. Haven't we seen Haven't
we seen uh like interviews with like 16-year-old girls with like
uh Sansa Stark or Hermione or whatever where they talk about
like, "Oh, and I had this scene and we had a kiss and it was
so nice even though he's 25 and it was so blah blah blah blah."
Bro, this guy went way way off the map here. What are we doing?
We're talking about having close relationships and then dating
people and he's like, "Doesn't like don't actors like text each
other sometimes? Don't actors like have scenes where they kiss
or something?" It's like uh may maybe like I don't How is this
applicable? How is this equal at all? >> Like hasn't this
[__] like I'm sure these people text and talk with
each other like after they finish their final uh rap and everything.
I'm sure it happens and I'm sure >> Do you think there's
a difference between talking to your uh castmates and talking
to other celebrities in the >> Well, there you go. Aba
just nailed it immediately. Hey, don't you think that's like
not even remotely analogous to what we're talking about in any
way?